«إسرائيل» مخططها لم ينتهي بعد
«إسرائيل» مخططها توسعي كبير في المنطقة العربية وفي الشرق الأوسط
في الأزمة حقت غزة اللي الآن نشاهدها
تجد أن منظمة التحرير الفلسطينية مشتتة
وغير ماسكة زمام القيادة في الموضوع
كيف رغم وضوح وعدالة القضية على مدى كل هذه السنوات
لم يقف المجتمع الدولي موقف منصف لهذه القضية؟
أيش التقصير اللي صار مننا، وليش ما نجحنا؟
هذا سقراط من إذاعة ثمانية، وأنا عمر الجريسي
أستضيف قادة التحول وقادة الأعمال وقادة الرأي
ضيف حلقتنا اليوم هو معالي المهندس عبدالله بن يحيى المعلمي
خبير في الشؤون الدبلوماسية لسنوات طويلة
حلقة جدًّا فخور فيها، ومبسوط من توقيتها
لأنها قدمت سرد عقلاني وتاريخي
للقضية الفلسطينية والصراع العربي الإسرائيلي
يمكن أنا نشأت على علاقة عاطفية مع القضية
ومشكلة العلاقة العاطفية أنها إما تفتر أو تتغير أو يعاد توجيهها
وهذا يمكن شعور يلامس كثير من الجيل
لأنهم ما هم فاهمين تفاصيل وعدالة هذه القضية
فضيفنا اليوم سرد الحكاية من البداية
وفي كل محطة شرح الدور الفلسطيني والدور العربي
دور الاحتلال الإسرائيلي أو موقفه
الموقف الدولي وقرارات مجلس الأمن
الحروب الثلاثة الشهيرة، وما بعدها
الحراك الدبلوماسي اللي كان يقوده الملك «فهد»
والأمير «بندر بن سلطان» والملك «سعود الفيصل» لفترة معينة
مبادرة الملك عبدالله، الله يرحمه
وكل المواقف اللي شهدتها هذه القضية إلى الأحداث الحالية
تكلمنا على كل الأطروحات
وهنا يهمني جدًّا أن السادة المستمعين والمشاهدين
ما يحكمون على أسئلتي وكأنها آرائي الشخصية
أنا كان من واجبي أني أجمع كل الآراء قدر المستطاع المؤيدة والمعارضة
وأطرحها على الضيف حتى نسمع تعليقه عليها
فليس بضرورة كل شيء طرحته يمثل وجهة نظري
على سبيل المثال موقف حماس
ودوره في تأجيج الصراع الفلسطيني
على فكرة أو أطروحة أن اليهود لهم حق في هذه الأرض
فيفترض أنهم يمكنوا منها
أطروحة أن احنا كسعوديين ليش نرهن مصالحنا في هذه القضية؟
ونربط كثير من مواقفنا بناءً عليها
رغم أن البعض في فلسطين يشيطن الدور السعودي، وينتقص منه
كثير من هذه الأطروحات طرحت على ضيفنا
ليس بالضرورة تمثل رأيي
لكنها أطروحات مهمة حتى نعطي القضية حقها
ونغطيها من كل الاتجاهات
وفي آخر اللقاء ختمنا بأسئلة عامة عن السياسة الخارجية السعودية
أيش اللي تغير أو أيش التحول اللي يعيشه هذا القطاع
تحت رؤية سعودية 2030؟
وختمنا بمجموعة من أسئلتكم الثمينة المرتبطة بشخص الضيف نفسه
أصعب أيامه في العمل الدبلوماسي، والمواقف اللي مر فيها
وأي نصائح يقدمها للجيل الحالي
أترككم مع الحوار
حيّاك الله أبو فارس شرفتنا ونورتنا
أهلًا وسهلًا أخ عمر
أنا آسف أني أقول لك: أبو فارس
لا، أبدًا ليش؟ أنا أعتز وأفتخر بهذا
أعطيتني حكاية الكنية، والموقف اللي صار في جدة
لكن وضحت لك إياها أنه هذا في مجال العمل الرسمي
لكن في مجال التعامل الشخصي يسعدني ويشرفني أنك تناديني
بس أيش الموقف اللي صار في جدة؟
عندما توليت العمل في الأمانة
وجدت أن كل الأخوان هناك يستعملون الكنية في التخاطب فيما بينهم
وإذا جاءني أحد يحكيني يقول لي: أبو فلان قال كذا
أقول له: من هو أبو فلان؟
يقول لي: زميلنا كذا
قلت له: يا أخي أنا الحين صار لي شهر وللا شهرين يلا بدأت أحفظ أسماءكم
الآن تبوني أحفظ أسماء أبنائكم كمان؟
لا، أنا أنصح بعدم استخدام الكنية
وإنما اللجوء إلى اللقب العلمي
أو الأخ فلان أو الأستاذ فلان
أو فلان باسمه الشخصي إذا كان بينك وبينه علاقة طيبة
وفعلًا بعد كذا اختفت
الكنية
من الأمانة
بس احنا هنا اتفقنا مسموح، لأنه بما أنه هذا إطار غير رسمي
إطار ودي نعم
تسلم والله احنا سعداء بقبولك الدعوة
وأتخيل، ما شاء الله، هذا من أوائل اللقاءات بعد مرحلة التقاعد
فكيف التقاعد؟
والله التقاعد ممتع مثلما يقولوا
هذه دائمًا ممتع هي المصطلح المغلف إيجابًا لمرحلة ما هي جيدة
لا، هي مرحلة فيها تكيف وتحدي
وضروري أن الواحد يتعلم كيف يستفيد من وقته؟
وكيف يستفيد من هذه المرحلة، وأيش يسوي فيه؟
لأن الفراغ قاتل
والحمد لله، أنا لا أشكو من الفراغ
أشكوه كشيء من كثرة المهام الموكلة لي
والحمد لله، هذا أمر يسعدني، وأنا سعيد بمثل هذا اللقاء
كأحد وسائل التغلب على التقاعد
واحنا أسعد، الله يسلمك
ويمكن بعد، ما شاء الله، مسيرة فيها
خبرات وقطاعات متنوعة ما بين الطاقة والصناعة والاستثمار
والعمل الحكومي في الشورى والقطاع البلدي في أمانة جدة
والعمل الدبلوماسي في السفارة ثم في البعثة الدائمة
أنا أعرف أن هذا السؤال غير محبب
بس أني عندي فضول أعرف أيها أقرب لقلبك أو أيها تحن إليه أكثر؟
اليوم بعدما بدأ التقاعد
والله أكثر مجال يمكن ينطبق عليه هذا الوصف
أو الحنين أكثر أو التفاعل معاه
هو مجلس الشورى
أنا عشت في الشورى أربع سنوات
وأعتقد أنها كانت سنوات ثرية
لأنك في مجلس الشورى تتطلع على كل مرافق الدولة
وتطلع على تقارير من كل الوزارات والمؤسسات والجهات
وهذه التقارير تعطيك معلومات ثرية
حول الوضع السائر في البلد والإدارات الحكومية، وما إلى ذلك
ثم أنها تعطيك فرصة للقاء بعشرات الزملاء
الذين يأتون من مشارب ومن أنحاء مختلفة من السعودية
ويمثلون كل رقعة من رقاع السعودية
وبعضهم كان لا يمكن لك أن تسنح لك الفرصة لمقابلتهم
والتفاعل معهم والحديث معهم
فأعتقد أن مجلس الشورى كان جامعة وفرصة
للتعلم من الزملاء، والتعلم من التقارير الحكومية التي تصل إليه
ويمكن أنا لما تشرفت وزرتك بترتيب من فيصل، الله يعطيه العافية، في يونيو
كان الهدف أننا نسولف على التحول في القطاع الدبلوماسي
بما أني أنا مهتم برصد التحول في كل القطاعات
كان الحديث عن التحول في القطاع الدبلوماسي
وجاء بس كذا على هامش اللقاء حديث جانبي
على موضوع قضية فلسطين والموقف منها
ونظرة الأجيال الجديدة لها فتشعبنا فيها
ووجدت أنها هي يمكن فيها محتوى أدسم من كلما سبق
فقلنا: نبي نخصص حلقة عنها، سبحان الله، تصادفت مع الأحداث
اللي نعيشها هذه الفترة
نعم
فأظنها بتأخذ حيز كبير من حلقة اليوم
فودي أبدأ معك، الله يسلمك
بأننا نرجع للتاريخ ونقول: كيف بدأت هذه القضية؟
بدأت هذه القضية بعد الحرب العالمية الأولى
عندما نشأت الحركة الصهيونية في أوربا
وتداعت هذه الحركة إلى تكثيف الهجرة إلى فلسطين
وإلى تأسيس دولة قومية لليهود على أرض فلسطين
لم تلقى هذه الحركة استجابة كبيرة في البداية
ولكن بعد فترة من الزمن تقريبًا تبنتها بريطانيا
وثبت ذلك عن طريق «وعد بلفور» الذي مُنِح لليهود
بأن المملكة المتحدة تؤيد أو تنظر بعطف
لطموحات اليهود في إقامة دولة يهودية في فلسطين
ونتيجةً لذلك تم تشجيع الهجرة اليهودية إلى فلسطين
وتم تسليح اليهود في فلسطين
حتى آالوقت لانسحاب بريطانيا
التي قررت أن تنسحب بدون تنسيق مسبق مع الأطراف
خاصة مع الأطراف العربية
وتركت...، في هذه الأثناء كانت الجمعيات والجماعات اليهودية
والعصابات اليهودية المسلحة
أكثر تنظيمًا وأكثر استعدادًا من الجانب العربي في فلسطين
وبالتالي استطاعوا أن يعلنوا إنشاء دولة فلسطين
وأن يستندوا في ذلك على قرارات الأمم المتحدة
يعلنوا دولة «إسرائيل»
عفوًا دولة «إسرائيل»
ويستندوا في ذلك على قرار الأمم المتحدة
بتقسيم فلسطين إلى دولتين، دولة يهودية وعربية
وقالوا: نعم احنا نقبل بذلك
الفلسطينيين لم يضيعوا فرصة، لأن يضيعوا فرصة
فكان ردة فعل الفلسطينيين
أن لا، احنا لا نقبل، هذه فلسطين أرضنا وديارنا
وأنتوا جايين ضيوف مهاجرين أهلًا وسهلًا
تبوا تجوا تعيشوا معنا أهلًا وسهلًا، ما تبوا تجو تعيشوا معنا فلترحلوا
ثم قامت الحرب العربية الإسرائيلية الأولى في 1948
وهُزِمت الجيوش العربية مع الأسف في تلك الحرب
وأعلن قيام دولة «إسرائيل»
وراح نجي على موضوع الحرب وتداعياتها
بس برجع آسف خطوة سامحني
ليش اليهود ما هم قادرين يعيشون في أوربا؟
ليش محتاجين يهاجرون؟ وليش تم اختيار فلسطين؟
اليهود اضطهدوا في أوربا
وكانت ذروة الاضطهاد لهم في ألمانيا
في الحرب العالمية الثانية اللي تعرض فيها اليهود لمحرقة كبيرة
ومات منهم، حسب ما يقال 5 أو 6 ملايين شخص
وأعداد كبيرة منهم هربوا إلى أماكن مختلفة
منهم من هرب إلى دول المغرب العربي في شمال أفريقيا
ومنهم من هرب إلى إسبانيا
وإلى روسيا كذلك
وإلى روسيا، وإلى غيرها من الأماكن
ومنهم من هرب إلى فلسطين
وليش كانوا مضطهدين؟ ليش كان غير مرحب فيهم في أوربا؟
والله هذا سؤال تاريخي صعب
اليهود طوال حياتهم كانوا غير منسجمين مع المجتمعات والبيئات التي يعيشون فيها
لهم خصال شخصية
أنا لا أريد أن أسهب في ذلك حتى لا أتهم باللاسامية
وبتقديم صفات لليهود حسب ما الصورة الكاركاتيرية الشائعة عنهم
أنهم يحبون المال ويحبون كذا
وهم فعلًا كانوا مسيطرين على المال والإعلام وأشياء كثيرة
وهذه كانت تسبب ردود فعل سلبية اتجاههم وخاصةً في أوربا
لأن في أوربا كان احتكاك الأوربيين باليهود أكثر
فلسطين بالنسبة لهم كانت تمثل شيء من الحلم
وأولًا: هناك علاقة تاريخية كما يدعون
وثانيًا: فلسطين أرض جميلة وبلد حلوة وكذا
وثالثًا: نشروا شائعة أن فلسطين أرض بلا شعب
لشعب بلا أرض، وهم اليهود
وهي كانت مغالطة تاريخية كبرى
فلسطين اتضح أن فيها شعب وناس وكذا
ولكن هم دخلوا للحرب، وقتلوا من قتلوا من الفلسطينيين
وهجروا أعداد كبيرة منهم إلى الخارج، ونشأت مشكلة اللاجئين الفلسطينيين
وقامت دولة «إسرائيل»
ومن ثم بدأ الصراع العربي الإسرائيلي أو الفلسطيني الإسرائيلي
وكان في أكثر من خيار قدموه الإنقليز لليهود
يقال أن كان هناك خيارات أخرى لإقامة الدولة الفلسطينية
أحدها كان أن تقام الدولة «الإسرائيلية» في وسط أمريكا
وأمريكا أرض شاسعة، وفيها صحاري وأماكن خضراء وسهول وكذا
وكان بالإمكان أن يختاروها هناك
قالوا: لا، أمريكا بعيدة، وصعب تجميع اليهود فيها وكذا
ثم قيل: فليكن في أفريقيا
أوقندا
أوقندا على وجه التحديد كانت مطروحة كبديل
ولكن في النهاية اليهود قرروا أن الأرض الجميلة الحلوة
اللي جوها معتدل، وأرضها سخية وخصبة
وفيها ارتباط تاريخي بالنسبة لهم
وفي رابط تاريخي يدعون أنه يبرر لهم ذلك
الرابط التاريخي هذا ما أبغى أدخل بشكل عميق في القضايا التاريخية
لكن الرابط ضعيف للغاية
لا يمكن إدّعاء أن اليهود الموجودين حاليًا
هم فعلًا من نسل اليهود اللي عاشوا في فلسطين قبل 2000 سنة
ثم أنه قيام اليهود في ذلك التاريخ
باحتلال أو العيش في فلسطين لمدة سبعين سنة
لا يعطيهم الحق لأن يكونوا هم الملاك المطلقين لهذه الأرض
العرب المسلمين عاشوا في فلسطين على مدى 1400 سنة متواصلة
وكانوا دائمًا هم الملاك والقادة خلال السنوات هذه كلها
فإذن هذه كانت فلسفتهم في...
في اختيار فلسطين
وحسب ما قرأت أن كانت فترة من الحرب العالمية الأولى
إلى الحرب العالمية الثانية من الهجرة
أو تشجيع اليهود أنهم يهاجرون
وهنا دائمًا يصير في الاتهام المبطن
أنه كانوا هؤلاء المهاجرين يجون ويشترون أراضي وبيوت
ويتملّكون بطريقة سلمية
كيف نرد على هذا الأمر إذا كان صحيح وللا مغالطة؟
يجوز أنه كان صحيح أو جزء منه كان صحيح
المهاجرين الأوائل، الدفعة الأولى
المهاجرين الأوائل، وأعتقد أن الفلسطينيين يمكن لم يدركوا
أن بيع الأرض بهذا الشكل كان يمكن أن يشكل بداية لضياع الأرض بالكامل
لكنهم في الواقع لم يكتفوا بشراء الأرض من الفلسطينيين
وإنما كانت هناك محاولات مستمرة لإخلاء المنازل من السكان الفلسطينيين
واحنا نرى اليوم في غزة كيف أن «إسرائيل»
تدفع بأكثر من مليون مواطن فلسطيني دفعًا للخروج من منازلهم وتركها
والذهاب إلى أماكن أخرى
اللي حصل في 1948 لا يختلف كثيرًا عن ما يحدث حاليًّا
أن هناك ضغط قوي وشديد من قبل «إسرائيل»
بتعويض أحيانًا، وبدون تعويض أحيانًا أخرى
لإخراج الفلسطينيين من منازلهم ومن ديارهم، وذهبوا إلى دار الشتات
وراحوا كلاجئين في الأردن وسوريا ومصر وفلسطين ولبنان وغيرها
وفي هذاك الظرف التاريخي لما بدأ يتزايد عدد المهاجرين اليهود
وبدأ الفلسطينيين أو أصحاب الأرض يتضايقون منهم
فبدأ يصير في تصعيد للمستعمر الإنقليزي فأقام أظن في عام 1939
أشبه بمؤتمر لإيجاد حل أو التوافق بين الطرفين، ما وصل إلى حل
فرماها على الأمم المتحدة
وخرج في عام 1947 أو 1948
وهناك كان قرار الأمم المتحدة، قرار 181
بتقسيم فلسطين بين جزء «إسرائيلي» وجزء فلسطيني
نعم
هنا كانت أعتقد الضربة القاسية بأن اليهود قبلوا
فثبت حقهم، ونالوا اعتراف دولي
الفلسطينيين لم يقبلوا
لأنهم كانوا يرون نفسهم مظلومين
هم يمثلون 90% من السكان، ولم يعطوا إلا 45% من الأرض فرفضوا
صحيح
هل كان هذا الرفض خطأ تاريخي؟
والله شوف صعب الحديث أو الحكم بصورة قطعية عما إذا كان هذا الرفض خطأ تاريخي
بالنظر للأحداث من خلفية الواقع الحالي
نستطيع أن نقول: أنه كان خطأ تاريخي
لو قبلوا بما عرض عليهم في ذلك الوقت، وسعوا إلى المزيد عبر السنوات
لربما كانت النتائج تكون أفضل
لكن إذا أردت أن تقيم هذا القرار لا بد أن تقيمه بعقلية السنة التي أتُخذ فيها
والقرار العربي برفض التقسيم، وما إلى ذلك
يجب أن ننظر إليه بعقلية وبموازين تلك الفترة
بموازين تلك الفترة كان العرب بوجهة نظرهم أنه ليش؟
مش بس الفلسطينيين، وإنما العرب
أنه ليش نتقاسم هذه الأرض مع هؤلاء الغزاة المحتلين؟
لا بد من مقاومتهم والحفاظ على وحدة فلسطين وكذا وكذا
إذا يبغوا يساعدوا اليهود فليساعدوهم في أي مكان آخر
الفلسطينيين أبدوا استعدادهم للتعاون مع اليهود في داخل فلسطين
بإعطائهم بعض الحقوق الاستثنائية، وما إلى ذلك
ولكن في النهاية اليهود تمسكوا بما لديهم، وسعوا إلى المزيد
والعرب رفضوا ما هو موضوع بين يديهم
وطالبوا...، وأصروا على الكل، ومن هنا جاءت المشكلة
وبعد الانسحاب البريطاني، وبعد هذا القرار الأممي
فُجِرت الاصطدامات بين الإسرائيليين أو المحتل الاحتلال الإسرائيلي
والعرب عمومًا
أيش تذكر أو تعرف عن معركة أو حرب 1948؟
لا أذكر شيء مباشر لأنه هذا كان...
قبل ميلادك، الله يحفظك
قبل ميلادك أنت أيضًا
لكن المعروف تاريخيًّا أن كانت الحرب قامت بين سبع دول عربية
وبين دولة «إسرائيل»
قد يقال: أن سبع دول عربية المفروض أنها تكون تغلب «إسرائيل»
وتهزمها وكذا
ولكن واقع الأمر أنه تشتت القدرة العربية عبر سبع جيوش
وتشتت القيادة، وتشتت وغياب وحدة الصف بين العرب في ذلك الوقت
هو الذي أدى إلى الانقسام والهزيمة
لاحظ أن اليهود كانوا يحاربون البريطانيين في نفس الوقت
لأن البريطانيين في نفس الوقت كانوا يحاولون محاولات بائسة وخجولة
للحفاظ على الأمن والسلم داخل فلسطين
لمحاولة إيجاد شيء من التوازن بين الطرفين
وفي النهاية البريطانيين هربوا وانسحبوا انسحابًا ذليلًا خنوعًا جبانًا
لأنهم تركوا المشكلة بدون حل وانسحبوا وتركوها
اليهود كانوا مستعدين
من ناحية التنظيم والعتاد والأموال والأفراد
واستطاعوا أنهم فورًا يستولوا على مراكز القرار
ويستولوا على مباني الجهات الحكومية
ويسيروا عجلة الدولة «الإسرائيلية» الجديدة
العرب كانوا شبه يتفرجوا على هذا الكلام
اصبر واستنى خليني ألحق فيك، وأسوي مثلك، وأعمل كذا، ما ينفع
ونتيجةً لذلك جاءت قضية الهزيمة الأولى، أو ما يسمى بالنكبة
مين كان يشارك فيها من الجيوش العربية؟
سبع دول عربية اللي هي الدول اللي اشتركت في النهاية في الجامعة العربية
كان في مصر والمملكة العربية السعودية
والعراق وسوريا والأردن ولبنان واليمن، هذه هي الدول
المشاركة الرئيسية كانت مصر وسوريا والأردن
والمشاركة المساندة كانت العراق والمملكة العربية السعودية
المملكة العربية السعودية قواتها راحت إلى جهتين إلى الأردن ومصر
وفي الجهتين كانت تحت قيادة القيادات المحلية في الأردن ومصر
العراقيين كانوا يفترض أنهم يساندوا الأردن وسوريا
ولكن العراقيين وصلوا للحدود، وتوقفوا عندها
وقالوا العبارة الشهيرة: ماكو أوامر
ماكو أوامر، فما دخلوا؟
ما دخلوا، وأن ما عندهم أوامر بالالتحام باليهود
اليمن مشاركتها كانت رمزية في هذا الشأن
المشاركة الأساسية كانت من مصر وسوريا في الحرب
وهزمت مصر وسوريا في هذه الحرب
نتيجة عدم تكافؤ القوة، ونتجة مشكلة الأسلحة الفاسدة
اللي كانت بأيدي الجيش المصري، ونتيجة عوامل كثيرة متعددة
وكان من أهم آثارها هي موضوع التمدد «الإسرائيلي»
«إسرائيل» استولت بموجب هذا الوضع على أجزاء كبيرة من اللقب
«جنوب إسرائيل»
وعلى أجزاء كبيرة من الجليل شمال شرق «إسرائيل»
وكل هذه الأجزاء ما كانت مسندة «لإسرائيل» في اتفاقية التقسيم
ودخلوا على سينا؟
لا، ما دخلوا سينا في حرب 1948، دخلوها في الحروب التالية
وهذه دائمًا الحرب شهيرة بموضوع الإجلاء
اللي صار لمجموعة من الفلسطينيين اللي تم إخراجهم من الأرض
ومجموعة أخرى اللي يسمون عرب فلسطين أو عرب الـ1948
اللي هم اضطروا يبقون، ولكن بهويات «إسرائيلية»
وفي هذه المجموعة البعض يطعن في سلوك بعض الناس
اللي أخذوا تعويضات وخرجوا في هذه الفترة
ودي أسمع تعليقك على كل هذه الأحداث
في ذلك الوقت العرب في فلسطين
كانوا مشتتين، وكان ما عندهم القيادة
القيادة كانت للحاج «أمين الحسيني» الله يرحمه
لكن ما في قيادة عسكرية وسياسية فعالة
الحاج «أمين الحسيني» كان يتهم بموالاته لألمانيا
وهذا ما كان يمكن أن يؤدي به للحصول على أي دعم من الغرب بصفة عامة
لكن اللي حصل أن كانت هناك ضغوط على الفلسطينيين
أنهم يغادروا
أنهم يغادروا أراضيهم اللي يقبل التعويض يأخد التعويض
واللي ما يقبل التعويض يطلع برا بدون تعويض وبدون شيء
وكانت الفكرة السائدة لدى العرب عمومًا
ولدى الفلسطينيين على وجه الخصوص أن هذا الخروج مؤقت
وكلها يومين أو ثلاثة أو أسبوعين أو ثلاثة أو شهرين أو ثلاثة
القوى العربية يعاد استجماعها وترتيب صفوفها
ثم تعود مرةً أخرى لتحرير فلسطين
هذا الأمل ظل يراود الشعوب العربية عشرات السنين
في كل حرب تقوم بين العرب و«إسرائيل»
يكون هذا هو الأمل، ويوم العودة والنصر، إلى آخره
إذا جئنا على محور سؤالك
وهو القبول بالتعويضات أو عدم القبول بالتعويضات
أنا لا أظن أن هذا كان عنصر أساسي في العملية
ما كان لهم خيار
واحنا شفنا الآن اليوم هذا احنا نشاهد
أن هناك ضغوط عديدة على الفلسطينيين لمغادرة غزة
مليون فلسطيني يغادر غزة
إذا هاجر مليون فلسطيني خارج غزة لن يعودوا إلى فلسطين
لن يعودوا إلى غزة
وستكون أزمة لاجئين أخرى جديدة
لا تقل حجمًا عن أزمة اللاجئين الأولى
اللي بموجبها هاجر الفلسطينيين إلى الأماكن المختلفة
مرة أخرى من الصعب أن تضع نفسك في موضع صانع القرار في ذلك الوقت
إذا كنت أنت أب لأسرة وعندك أطفال وعائلة وكذا
وأمامك جندي «إسرائيلي» مُدجج بالسلاح يطالبك بإخلاء البيت اللي أنت فيه
وأمامك شخص آخر يعرض عليك تسهيلات في أنك تنتقل إلى لبنان أو الأردن
أو غيرها من الأماكن
من الصعب أننا اليوم نحكم على هؤلاء الناس حكم قاطع
أن والله لا كانوا خونة وللا كانوا باعوا القضية
وللا مش عارف أيش، ومن هذا القبيل
أعتقد أن هذا الحكم الأخلاقي صعب جدًّا لمن لم يعش الظرف
وماذا عن اللي بقوا؟
اللي بقوا...
اللي هم عرب الـ1948 يسمون؟
هم عرب 1948 وهم جزئين، جزء بقوا كلاجئين
انتقلوا من بيوتهم في حيفا ويافا واللد والقدس وأماكن أخرى
انتقلوا وأقيمت لهم مخيمات لاجئين
وبالتالي أصبحوا لاجئين فلسطينيين
في بلدهم
في بلدهم في «إسرائيل»
وموجود إلى الآن بعض المخيمات للاجئين الفلسطينيين في داخل «إسرائيل»
والبعض الآخر قرر أن يقبل عرض «إسرائيل» بمنحهم الجنسية الإسرائيلية
والبقاء في «إسرائيل» كمواطنين إسرائيليين
لهم كل الحقوق والمزايا
وعمرهم ما حصلوا على الحقوق والمزايا المتساوية مثل المواطن الإسرائيلي
لأنهم دائمًا كانوا موضع الشك والريبة من قبل «إسرائيل»
في أن هؤلاء تعاطفهم مع العرب والقضية الفلسطينية
لكن بقي في «إسرائيل» أعتقد نص مليون أو 600 ألف
لا أعلم العدد الآن قديش بالضبط
لكن بقي في «إسرائيل» عدة مئات من الآلاف من عرب فلسطين
الذين ظلوا في داخل «إسرائيل»
كان الملك عبدالعزيز، الله يرحمه، له موقف ونصيحة
كان يوجهها دائمًا للقادة العرب مكونة من نقطتين، لو تذكرنا فيها
الملك عبدالعزيز، رحمة الله عليه، كان له موقف تاريخي مشهود
وكان هذا موقف المملكة العربية السعودية إلى اليوم
وهو يا جماعة يا عرب اتركوا الفلسطينيين يتحكموا في أمورهم بأنفسهم
ولا تسيطروا عليهم وتسيطروا على قرارهم وإرادتهم وتصرفاتهم
وإنما ادعموهم
ادعموهم بالسلاح وبالمال، وبكل ما يحتاجون إليه، وقفوا من خلفهم
لأن هم أدرى بشؤون بلادهم وبأراضيهم، وبكلما في هذا الأمر
بعض القوى الأخرى في الوطن العربي في العالم العربي
ما كانت تحبذ هذه النصيحة لأن هذه النصيحة تسحب نفوذهم
وهم كانوا يريدون أو بعضهم على الأقل
كان يريد أن يستمر في استغلال القضية الفلسطينية
مصدر رزق وشعبية وسلطة ونفوذ، وإلى آخر ذلك
الأردن ضاعفت عدد سكانها بمقدار الضعف
وأعطتهم الجنسية الأردنية فورًا، واستوعبتهم
وصارت المملكة الأردنية الهاشمية
قبلها كانت إمارة شرق الأردن قبل حرب فلسطين
بعدها صارت المملكة الأردنية الهاشمية
وبعدد من السكان أكثر من ضعف العدد السابق
مصر استوعبت أعداد قليلة من الفلسطينيين
مصر، ما شاء الله، دولة كبيرة يضيع فيها الفلسطينيين
لكن معظم الفلسطينيين اللي راحوا لمصر ظلوا يعتبروا لاجئين
وكانوا يتعاملوا ببطاقة عبور
وبوثائق سفر من سفرة إلى أخرى
ما عندهم جوازات سفر وهوية، وما يستطيعوا يرجعوا إلى بلدهم
لأن «إسرائيل» بطبيعة الحال ما تصدق على الله أن أحد يترك
تقول له: مع السلامة، وتسهل له الذهاب بدون عودة
وهذه كانت النقطة الأولى بأنه اترك الفلسطينيين يقودون وادعموهم
النقطة الثانية كانت بخصوص منع السماح للمهاجرين
الملك عبدالعزيز كان يوصي بعدم السماح للمهاجرين الفلسطينيين
أن يستقروا في الدول العربية، ليش؟
هذه النقطة أخذتها الدول العربية مجتمعة
قرروا الدول العربية مجتمعة
أن من أجل إبقاء القضية حية، وعدم تذويبها
أن ينبغي على الدول العربية أن لا تبادر إلى منح الجنسية المحلية للاجئين الفلسطينيين
وأنه إذا مُنحوا الجنسية المحلية
فأنهم سينخرطون في المجتمعات اللي هم فيها
وينسوا فلسطين والقضية، وإلى آخره
الدولة الوحيدة اللي لم تلتزم بذلك كانت الأردن
الأردن أعطت جنسية أردنية لأعداد كبيرة من الفلسطينيين
لكن بقية الدول رفضت أن تمنح الفلسطينيين الجنسية
ربما يكون في تفسير إيجابي لهذا الكلام من ناحية أنه أبقى القضية حية
لكنه في الوقت نفسه أبقى المأساة حية على الفلسطينيين أنفسهم في المخيمات
وفي الشتات وفي أماكن أخرى
بعد هذه الحرب بدأت منظمات التحرير تتحرك وللا لا؟
منظمة «الفتح» أعتقد تأسست بعد هذه الحرب في الخمسينيات؟
أظن إذا ما خانتني الذاكرة أن «فتح» تأسست في وقت لاحق في منتصف الستينيات
أو في أوائل الستينيات
وقامت عدة منظمات مثلما تفضلت
وكان مركزها سوريا ولبنان والأردن ومصر
مصر جمعت هذه المنظمات تحت مظلة منظمة «التحرير الفلسطينية»
واختارت «أحمد الشقيري» رحمة الله عليه، لكي يكون...
هو الرئيس
رئيسًا لمنظمة «التحرير الفلسطينية»
منظمة «التحرير الفلسطينية» لم تكن أكثر
من مجرد أداة في أيدي المخابرات المصرية
وفي نفس الوقت لم يكن هناك سبب
كانت وسيلة لسيطرة مصر على القرار الفلسطيني
هذا الذي حدث فيما يتعلق بالمنظمات والوضع السياسي
بعدها جاءت الحرب الثانية، واللي كانت الحرب الأقسى
الأولى تسمى النكبة، وهذه تسمى النكسة أعتقد هي حرب 1967
قبل حرب 1967 كان حرب 1956
إي العدوان الثلاثي
صحيح
العدوان الثلاثي أيش كانت فكرته أو سببه؟
العدوان الثلاثي بدأ بأن مصر كانت تسعى لتمويل السد العالي
وكانت ترغب في إقامة السد العالي
مصر كانت تعاني من الفيضانات السنوية التي تأتي من نهر النيل
وتكتسح مساحات كبيرة
وفي الوقت نفسه ما كانت تستفيد من نهر النيل للحصول على طاقة كهربائية
وطلبت من العالم أن يساندها، وخاصةً البنك الدولي
أن يساندها في إنشاء السد العالي
والبنك الدولي رفض مساندة مصر، وأمريكا كذلك
فقررت مصر في ذلك الوقت أن تؤمم قناة السويس
وأن تستخدم العوائد الحاصلة من قناة السويس لتمويل السد العالي
هذا القرار أزعج بريطانيا وفرنسا بحكم أنهم كانوا من الدول الرئيسية المالكة
لشركة قناة السويس
وأزعج «إسرائيل» لأن بهذه الطريقة كان يمنع
الملاحة «الإسرائيلية»من العبور عبر قناة السويس إلى البحر الأحمر
وبالتالي يفصل بين «إسرائيل» في البحر المتوسط
عن «إسرائيل» في البحر الأحمر
ونتيجةً لذلك تصعدت تهديدات على مصر ثم انتهت إلى العدوان الثلاثي
الذي قامت به الثلاث دول
وبموجبه «إسرائيل» احتلت سيناء وغزة
والجزر المشرفة على الممرات في تيران وصنافير
واحتلت المراكز في سيناء رأس محمد وشرم الشيخ وغيرها
وبعدها بدأت الدبلوماسية تعمل
وكان هناك ضغط دبلوماسي مشترك بين روسيا وأمريكا على «إسرائيل»
للانسحاب
وعلى بريطانيا وفرنسا للانسحاب، وفعلًا تم الانسحاب في وقت لاحق
وبالتالي عادت الأراضي المحتلة إلى مصر
لكن الخازوق اللي حصل هو أن من ضمن شروط الجلاء
كان وجود قوات من الأمم المتحدة على خط الحدود
بين مصر و«إسرائيل» في داخل قطاع غزة
وفي جزر تيران وصنافير التي كانت في الواقع هي تابعة للمملكة العربية السعودية
والمملكة العربية السعودية سمحت لمصر بإدارتها والإشراف عليها
خلال مرحلة العدوان
قبل سنة 1956 لأنه كانت مهمة بالنسبة للممرات وللوضع الاستراتيجي
مصر فقدتها في حرب 1956
ونتيجةً لذلك كان أُقفلت الملاحة
بين البحر الأبيض المتوسط والبحر الأحمر في وجه «إسرائيل»
وهذا كان أمر غير مرغوب فيه عند «إسرائيل»
ولذلك قامت الحرب عندما قامت باكتساح سيناء
كانت قوات الأمم المتحدة قد انسحبت بناءً على طلب مصر
وتم وضع قوات «حفظ سلام» وللا هذه لاحقًا؟
هذه لاحقًا صارت في عام 1973 في حرب 1973
ففي المرحلة هذه ما بعد جاءت قوات «حفظ السلام»
في هذه المرحلة نُزعت قوات «حفظ السلام»
وعادت الأراضي لمصر
ولكن هذا فتح المجال أمام العدوان الثلاثي لأن يحصل
ونتيجةً لذلك احتلت مصر سيناء، وما إلى ذلك
ثم عادت وجلت عنها، وأعادتها إلى السلطة المصرية
وفي هذا الوقت تم وضع قوات الأمم المتحدة مرة أخرى
ومن ضمنها في الجزر السعودية
بعدها صار موضوع حرب 1967 وللا لا؟
نعم
أيش تداعيات الحرب هذه، وليش فُجِرت؟
حرب 1967 بدأت بأن كان هناك نظام حكم جديد في سوريا
وكان هذا نظام بعثي حزب البعث يستولى على السلطة في سوريا لأول مرة
وحزب البعث كان معروف من ذلك التاريخ
وإلى وقت قريب بالشعارات الرنانة وبالحماس وبكذا
وحزب البعث بدأ يتحرك على أنغام تحرير فلسطين، وما إلى ذلك
وضرورة العمل الفوري في هذا الاتجاه
وكان يزايد على «عبدالناصر» و«عبدالناصر» يزايد عليه
أن مين اللي بعمل لصالح القضية الفلسطينية أكثر؟
حزب البعث في سوريا يقول: أنتوا ما سويتوا شيء وأنتم كذا وكذا
ونتيجةً لذلك صار هناك حشد عسكري
بين «إسرائيل» وسوريا على هضبة الجولان
قوات عسكرية من الطرفين، وصل الحشد والتوتر إلى حد أقصى
وكانت «إسرائيل» تهدد بأنها ستكتسح الجولان، وتكتسح سوريا
وستسقط نظام الحكم في دمشق
وستقيم دولة نظام حكم جديد هناك وكذا
وكان هناك أسلوب تحدي لسوريا ولمصر
ومصر انجرفت في ذلك التيار
وأعلنت إخلاء منطقة سيناء من جنود الأمم المتحدة
وتقدم القوات المصرية إلى الحدود وقيام حشود كبيرة على الحدود مع «إسرائيل»
و«إسرائيل» صارت تصيح في العالم
الحقوني السوريين والمصريين يهددوني، ويحاصروني وكذا
وهي سبب المشاكل من البداية
ونتيجةً لذلك في هذه الأثناء كانت هناك عناصر ضعف عميقة
في المجتمع العربي عامةً، وفي المجتمع المصري خاصةً
الجيش المصري كان مُلتهي عن الحرب
وكانت قيادات الجيش المصري سهرانين لدى الحرب
وفي أماكن له...، ما كانوا مراقبين الموضوع بشكل جدي
ونتيجةً...
وكانوا مشغولين بموضوع اليمن وللا هذه جاءت بعدين؟
اليمن قبل، وكان جزء منها...
فكان جزء من الجيش موجود في اليمن للدعم
كان جزء كبير من الجيش موجود في اليمن
والنتيجة أنه قامت «إسرائيل» بهجوم كاسح صباح يوم 5 يونيو، 1967
أولًا على الجبهة المصرية واستولت على غزة وسيناء
ووقفت عند حدود قناة السويس
ثانيًا على سوريا استولت على الجولان بالكامل
ثالثًا على الأردن استولت على الضفة الغربية بالكامل بما فيها القدس الشريف
وكل أنحاء الضفة الغربية، وهذه ما سميت بحرب النكسة
لأنها كانت حرب ست أيام دمرت فيها كل القدرات
دمرت فيها كل القدرات، واستطاعت أن تثبت نفسها
ونالت إعجاب العالم مرة أخرى
لأن العالم يُعجب بالقوي وبالشخص الذي يأخذ زمام الأمور بيده
العالم كله كان يحذر «إسرائيل» من شن الحرب، ومن البدء في الحرب
«ديقول» رئيس فرنسا في ذلك الوقت حذر «إسرائيل»
من أنها ستفقد تأييد فرنسا، وفعلًا فقدته
لكن استعاضت عنه بتأييد أمريكا
لكن القضية بدأت تجابه معضلة
وهي أنك أنت الآن تواجه احتلال إسرائيلي جديد
والتوافق الروسي الأمريكي اللي كان في سنة 1956
على توجيه إنذار «إسرائيل» بالانسحاب لم يعد قائمًا
وأصبحت أمريكا ممالئة ومتواطئة مع «إسرائيل» في هذا الشأن
وهنا يمكن نقدر نقول: أنها كانت أكثر فترة فيها حالة انهزام وإحباط في العالم العربي
لأن القائد اللي كان ينظر له بشكل مختلف «جمال عبدالناصر»
الجيش المصري اللي كان ينظر له بأنه قوة لا تهزم، والجيش السوري
في ستة أيام هذا الكيان المحتل الصغير الجديد
استطاع أن يكتسحهم في ستة أيام فكانت نكسة حقيقية
لو تحدثنا عن أجواء هذيك المرحلة
وأيش القرار اللي اتخذه «جمال عبدالناصر»؟
أولًا أجواء تلك المرحلة كانت في بداية المرحلة قبل الحرب كانت أجواء انتعاش
بعد العدوان الثلاثي؟
لا، بعيد العدوان الثلاثي
بس الآن في فترة 1967 في شهر مايو ويونيو
كان هناك شعور بالانتعاش لدى الشارع العربي والمواطن العربي
أنه آن الأوان لتخليصنا من الاحتلال الإسرائيلي
الآن الجيوش العربية ستدخل، والآن كذا وكذا
ليش هذا الشعور من وين جاء، من الزعماء الجدد والثورات اللي صارت؟
من الحشود العسكرية اللي صارت بين سوريا و«إسرائيل»
وبين مصر و«إسرائيل»
والتهديدات المتبادلة بأنه احنا راح نفعل ونسوي
فكان المواطن العربي يشعر أن آنت ساعة الصفر
وأن الجيوش العربية ستدخل إلى «إسرائيل» وستحرر فلسطين
وانتهت القضية، وانتهى الموضوع
في ذلك الوقت كان هذا الشعور سائد
الأمة العربية صُدمت وذُهلت بنتائج حرب 1967
لأن حتى في الأيام الأولى من الحرب
ما كانوا يسمعوا إلا تقارير صوت العرب والإذاعة المصرية
بأنه أسقطنا كذا وعشرات الطائرات، واحتلينا كذا وسوينا كذا
وهو كله كان كذب لم يحدث شيء من هذا القبيل
وإنما كانت محاولة لتخدير المواطن العربي عن الشعور بالهزيمة
اللي كانت على الأبواب
سنة 1967 بعد ذلك نتيجةً للهزيمة «عبدالناصر» أعلن استقالته
وفي نفس الليلة خرجت جماهير الشعب المصري
تنادي بعودة الرئيس على الاستقالة
مو بس في مصر يبدو حتى في...
في أنحاء عديدة من العالم العربي
هذه المسرحية ربما نُظم لها من المخابرات المصرية
ربما كانت من الصعب أنك تشعر أن شعب يُهزم، ويرجع يطالب الرئيس
في نفس الوقت بالبقاء
اللي حصل أن «عبدالناصر» ثاني يوم تراجع عن الاستقالة
واتخذ إجراءات شديدة اتجاه قادة الجيش المصري
أعتقل عدد الكبير منهم «عبدالحكيم عامر» نائب الرئيس
وُضع في الإقامة الجبرية ثم انتحر أثناء وجوده في الإقامة الجبرية
وفي ذلك الوقت
بدأ ما يسمى إعادة بناء الجيش المصري
الجيش المصري تدمر تقريبًا إلى الصفر
وبدأ إعادة بناء الجيش المصري تمهيدًا لجولة قادمة
ومين مول هذا إعادة البناء؟
المملكة العربية السعودية
بسبب مصالحة السودان
بسبب المصالحة التي تمت في السودان على اليمن
المملكة العربية السعودية كان لها موقف نبيل في حرب 1967
كانت تدعم «عبدالناصر» ولم تقف عند حدود الأزمة
اللي بينها وبين «عبدالناصر» في اليمن
رغم أن طائراته كانت تضرب جنوب السعودية
مع أن طائراته كانت تضرب
لكن كان هذا موقف الشرفاء والعظماء
لأن احنا...
ننحي الخلاف الجانبي
ننحي الخلاف الجانبي، ونركز على القضية العربية
وندعم العرب في أي مكان
المملكة العربية السعودية في ذلك الوقت اتخذت إجراء بقطع البترول
عن أمريكا وهولندا
أعتقد هذا 1973 مو 1976؟
1973 صحيح
إي، راح نجيها الحين
1967 لا
لكن حتى في 1967 كان هناك تهديد بقطع البترول
بعد عام 1967، صار مؤتمر القمة في الخرطوم
اللي صار فيه اللاآت الثلاثة
لا للاعتراف ولا للتفاوض ولا للصلح مع «إسرائيل»
وقرر المؤتمر تقديم دعم مادي من السعودية والكويت وليبيا
لصالح مصر وسوريا في ذلك الوقت
أجواء كانت كئيبة وسيئة في العالم العربي كله
لأنه لأول مرة يواجه مجموعة
كجيل كامل يواجه حقيقة الفساد في أدوات الحكم العربي
الفساد في السياسة العربية الخارجية
الفساد في القيادة الداخلية مثل «عبدالحكيم عامر»
كان سهران طول الليل وكان...
الله أعلم أيش كان عنده مشاغل هامته
وتشغله عن قيادة الجبهة والمعركة اللي كانت تدور في ذلك الوقت
وبعد هذيك الهزيمة كان بالتوازي مع مرحلة بناء الجيش
كانت فيه استفزازات إسرائيلية بضرب المدارس ومواقع داخل مصر
وفي المقابل كانت في غواصة أو شيء زي كذا
ما بين الحربين، أيش كان المشهد؟
للشهور الأولى بعد 1967 كان هناك ركود وهدوء على الجبهة
لأنه كانت مصر ترغب في إعادة بناء جيشها
وساندها في ذلك الاتحاد السوفيتي
وساندتها الدول العربية، وعلى رأسها المملكة العربية السعودية
فكانت هناك فترة حوالي سنة أو أكثر
اللي فيها شيء من الهدوء النسبي
في تراشق أحيانًا في تبادل إطلاق نار وكذا
ثم بدأت بعد ذلك ما سُمي بحرب الاستنزاف
وهو أن الجيش المصري كل يوم يطلق صواريخ
ويطلق أسلحة على الإسرائيليين
ويضطرهم إلى أنهم يعملوا رد على مواقع الجيش المصري
لكن كانت حرب الاستنزاف بالدرجة الأولى تسير في صالح المصريين
وتستنزف قوى الإسرائيليين
استمرت هذه الحرب لفترة
لكن بعدين في النهاية «إسرائيل» بدأت تصعد لحجم الحرب
لأنها صارت تقول: أنتوا تبغوا حرب استنزاف؟ أعطيكم حرب استنزاف
بس ما أعطيكم حرب استنزاف بالمقاس اللي أنتوا تقرروه
وبدأت تضرب في العمق المصري، وضربت مدرسة «بحر البقر»
ومات فيها عشرات ربما مئات من الطلاب
وضربت مصنع الحديد الصُلب حوالين القاهرة
ومات فيها عدد كبير من العمال
وبدأت تضرب أهداف مدنية كثيرة
وفي هذا الوقت جاءت غواصة إسرائيلية
كانت تسير في البحر الأبيض المتوسط
وأرسلت القوات البحرية المصرية زوارق، ومعها صواريخ
وأطلقت النار على الغواصة وأغرقتها
كان هذا حدث معنوي إيجابي كبير بالنسبة للشعور النفسي العربي
لكن نتيجة كل هذه التراكمات والضغوط والبناء
بدأت أمريكا في التدخل لمحاولة تهدئة الوضع
والتوصل إلى وقف إطلاق النار
وفعلًا صارت وقفة الأقنار في فترة من الفترات
بعدها بفترة بسيطة توفى «جمال عبدالناصر»
ورئيس «السادات» جاء، وهدّى الأمور
وبدأ بمسيرة التفاوض مع الولايات المتحدة
والتفاوض هذا قبل حرب 1973؟
قبل حرب 1973
ما دامنا كنا في أجواء تفاوض
أيش اللي خلانا فجأة ندخل في حرب 1973؟
لأن التفاوض لم يكن يسير إلى أي نتيجة
«الإسرائييلن» كعادتهم ما راح يتركوا شيء إلا إذا أجبروا على ذلك
أمريكا ما كانت مستعدة أنها تجبر «إسرائيل» على شيء
وكانت تحاول تتفاهم معاها، و«إسرائيل» وجهة نظرها
أن احنا نحط شروطنا للسلام
وإذا العرب يبغوا يوقعوا عليها أهلًا وسهلًا، وإذا ما يبغوا بهواهم
فكان هذه الصورة
وفي النهاية حسب الرواية الشهيرة أن «هنري كيسنجر»
قال للسادات: إذا أنت تريد مني أنا شخصيًّا أن أتدخل
وأن أفعل شيئًا على غرار ما فعله في فيتنام
لأنه كان في فيتنام هو يتولى المفاوضات مع الفيتناميين
فعليكم أن تفعلوا شيئًا مثلما يفعل الفيتنامييون
أيش يفعل الفيتنامييون؟ تحريك المسألة
ولذلك كان الحوار أو الحديث في وقت لاحق عن حرب أكتوبر 1973
هل هي حرب تحرير أم حرب تحريك؟
هناك من كان يقول: أنها كانت حرب تحريك
أنه كان هدف «السادات» منها هو تحريك القضية فقط
ووجهة نظر أخرى أنها كانت حرب تحرير
لكن كان واضح الموقف الأمريكي أن في الوضع الحالي احنا ما نقدر نسوي شيء
إذا عندكم شيء جديد كلّمونا
ولذلك بدأ البناء والتوجه نحو حرب أكتوبر
وكانت تعتبر هي النصر العربي الوحيد في المعارك مع «إسرائيل» وللا لا؟
النصر...
أيش اللي صار فيها أول شيء؟ عفوًا
النصر والهزيمة أولًا...
نسبية؟
مقاييسها نسبية
في حرب 1956، طبعًا حرب 1948 كانت هزيمة مطلقة، ما فيها كلام
في حرب 1967 كانت هزيمة مطلقة، ما فيها كلام
حرب 1956 فيها تساؤل من الناحية العسكرية، كانت هزيمة مطلقة
لكن من الناحية السياسية مصر استعادت قناة السويس
هذا مكسب كان كبير
حرب 1973 كانت نصر في البداية ثم «إسرائيل»
قلبت ميزان القوة عندما استطاعت أن تدخل بثغرة الدفرسوار
إلى غرب قناة السويس
وأصبح هناك تلاحم بين الجيش المصري والجيش الإسرائيلي
وفض الاشتباك أصبح أصعب وهكذا
بس ودنا نأخذها من أولها، بعد إذنك
للي ما عاصروها أو ما عنده معلومات عنها
كيف بدأت، وشلون كان في تقدم عربي، ثم شلون صار الانقلاب؟
حرب 1973 الحق يقال: أنها ميزة للقيادة المصرية
لأنهم استطاعوا أنهم قاموا بالاستعداد لحرب أكتوبر 1973
اللي هي حرب رمضان
استعداد قوي واستعداد جيد
مباغت
إيوة مباغت، وقاموا بالتدريب وباستيعاب الأسلحة وبكذا
ووصلوا إلى مرحلة ساعة الصفر يوم 10 رمضان، 6 أكتوبر
وبدأوا بالهجوم على خط بارليف الشهير خط دفاعي حصين
«لإسرائيل» على الضفة الشرقية لقناة السويس
واستطاعوا خلال ساعات قليلة من تدمير فجوات كبيرة في خط بارليف
وبالتالي دخول الجيش المصري إلى شرق القناة، وسيطرته عليها تقريبًا
على مدى الأيام الباقية
«إسرائيل» دفعت بأرتال كبيرة من الدبابات غربًا
مصر قابلتها في وسط سيناء
وقصفت الدبابات الإسرائيلية بشكل مكثف
وفقدت «إسرائيل» أعداد كبير من أبنائها
ومن أعتادها ومن كذا في هذا الوقت
وبالتالي كانت كل الأمور متجه نحو هزيمة ساحقة «لإسرائيل»
إلى أن جاء جنرال إسرائيلي اسمه «أرئيل شارون»
اللي أصبح في وقت لاحق وزيرًا للدفاع
ثم رئيسًا للحكومة «الإسرائيلية»
واستطاع أن يأخذ فرقة صغيرة، وأن يسير نحو منطقة الدفرسوار
وكانت نقطة التلاقي بين الجيشين الثاني والثالث المصري على قناة السويس
وشعر بأن هناك في ثغرة ما يسمى بثغرة الدفرسوار
وطلب الإذن بالهجوم عن طريق هذه الثغرة، والتوجه نحو الضفة الغربية للقناة
«إسرائيل» رفضت منح «شارون» هذا الإذن
وأكدت عليه بأن لا تفعل ذلك
«شارون» قفل جهازه اللاسلكي أو وطى الصوت
وقال: أنا لا أسمعك
وفي الآخر قال لهم: شكرًا أنا فهمتكم أنكم موافقين، وراح ونفذ الثغرة هذه
واللي كانت أشبه بكماشة على الجيش المصري
اللي صار أمامه جيش إسرائيلي، وخلفه جيش إسرائيلي صحيح؟
بالضبط، والجيش الثاني كان على السويس في جنوب قناة السويس
هذا دخل من غرب الجيش المصري اللي كان في الجيش الثاني يسمى
اللي كان في السويس والتف حوالينه من الجنوب
في البداية كانت القوات الإسرائيلية اللي دخلت أعدادها قليلة
ولو أن مصر التفتت إليها لكانت سحقتها
لكن كان ينبغي لمصر لكي تفعل ذلك أن تسحب جيوش لها
من شرق قناة السويس، الجيوش اللي اقتحمت شرق قناة السويس
ومصر لم تكن تريد ذلك، لأن هذا إنجاز تاريخي عظيم يسجل لها
وكانت تظن إنها تستطيع إنها تتعامل مع الثغرة هذه لاحقًا
وبقوات أقل وبتضحيات أقل
في النهاية الجيش الإسرائيلي بدأ يتدفق أكثر وأكثر
إلى أن أصبح يحوط الجيش المصري الثاني
ومنع عنه المياه والغذاء والسلاح، وكل ذلك
في هذه الأثناء بدأ «كسينجر» جولاته المكوكية للتفاوض
وانتهت باتفاقية فض الاشتباكة الأولى
اللي بموجبها تراجع الجيشين عن مواقعهم
ثم في النهاية سحب الجيش الإسرائيلي لشرق القناة
وبعدين صارت المفاوضات اللاحقة في «كامب ديفيد» وإلى آخره
والسوريين من الجهة الثانية أيضًا كان لهم حراك وللا لا؟
السوريين من الجهة الثانية كان لهم حراك في بداية الحرب
واستطاعوا أنهم يستولوا على بعض الأراضي الفلسطينية خلينا نقول
ما نقول الإسرائيلية
لكن استطاعوا أنهم يستولوا على بعض الأراضي في داخل «إسرائيل»
ولكن بعدما تطمئنت «إسرائيل» للجبهة المصرية
التفتت له
وضعت كل ثقلها في سوريا واستطاعت أنها تدحر السوريين
وتخرجهم من الأماكن اللي احتلوها
وتخرجهم حتى من بعض أماكن أخرى
وبعدين توقف القتال هناك بموجب اتفاقيات فض الاشتباك
ويمكن الحدث التاريخي بعدها صار أن صدر قرار
بإقرار رقم 338 من الأمم المتحدة بوقف إطلاق النار
وتسليم الأراضي لأصحابها سواءً في مصر أو سوريا
والحدث الشهير اللي هو اتفاقية السلام بين مصر وبين «إسرائيل»
لو تحدثنا عن هذا الحدث
هناك القرار 242 اللي صدر بعد 1967
ثم 338 اللي صدر بعد 1973 وكلاهما ينص على عدم جواز احتلال أراضي الغير بالقوة
وعلى ضرورة السلام والاعتراف بـ«إسرائيل» وما إلى ذلك
وكان هو أساس الشرعية الدولية، وما يزال إلى الآن هو أساس قائم
ومرجعية قائمة للقضية الفلسطينية
أو القضية العربية الإسرائيلية
ثم بعد ذلك...أيش كان سؤالك؟ عفوًا
كان على موضوع «كامب ديفيد»
«كامب ديفيد»
من وجهة نظر «السادات» حسب ما يروي في كتبه وخطاباته وكذا
إن كانت القضية تراوح مكانها
صار فض الاشتباك الأول وانسحبت «إسرائيل»
عن خط القناة، وأخليت المنطقة اللي في غرب السويس
لكن الوضع القائم الأساسي وهو وجود «إسرائيل» كقوة محتلة ما زال قائم
قناة السويس لم يكن بمقدور مصر إنها تفتحها
لأن «إسرائيل» في الجهة الثانية تُهدد
فكان التوجه والرغبة هو في تحريك القضية
والتوجه إلى مسار المفاوضات
ونتيجةً لذلك «أنور السادات» قرر أولًا يستبعد قوات الاتحاد السوفيتي
اللي كانت موجودة في مصر طلعها عشان يأخذ حظوة عند أمريكا
أن هذا احنا طلعنا لكم الروس
وبعد ذلك اعتمد على أمريكا اعتماد وثيق
في محاولة التوصل إلى الحل
وكان «كيسنجر» هو عراب الحل في المنطقة
يروح ويأتي بين الطرفين
في هذه الأثناء انتهى حكم الرئيس «نيكسون»
وبعده «فورد» وجاء بعده «كارتر»
فـ«كيسنجر» انتهت مهمته خلال تلك الفترة
لكن «كارتر» تولى الموضوع
وهو الذي حث الإسرائيليين والمصريين على التفاوض
الرئيس «السادات» كان رئيس درامي
ورأى أن لا بد يعمل حركة سينمائية ومفاجئة تقلب الصحون من على الطاولة
ولذلك أعلن في مجلس النواب المصري
أن أنا مستعد أن أذهب إلى آخر الدنيا من أجل السلام في مصر وفلسطين
والشرق الأوسط
وأنا مستعد أن أذهب حتى إلى القدس لمخاطبة «إسرائيل» من عقر دارها
حول هذا الموضوع
هو نزل من المنصة و«إسرائيل» على طول أصدرت بيان
تقول: أنها ترحب بالرئيس «السادات» وأهلًا وسهلًا فيه في أي وقت
يرغب أن يجي، وتم ترتيب الزيارة إلى القدس بعدها بأيام قليلة
وراح «السادات» في حدث تاريخي لا يُنسى
كانت مشاعري أنا شخصيًّا كانت تكتسحني مشاعر ألم شديد
أن يُرى رئيس أكبر دولة عربية
وهو ينزل سلّم الطائرة في القدس تحت الكاميرات والأنظار
وأن يوجد أمامه صف طويل من المستقبلين الإسرائيليين
ومن الزعامات التاريخية
اللي كنا دائمًا نذكرها ونلعنها، وندعي عليها
بما فيهم «قولدا مائير» و«موشي ديان»
وكلهم كانوا خرجوا من الحكم
لكن كلهم رجعوا لاستقبال «أنور السادات»
وراح «أنور السادات» من هناك إلى كنيسة «الإسرائيلي»
وألقى الخطاب الشهير اللي ألقاه هناك
واللي أعلن فيه إن احنا مستعدين نمد لكم يد السلام وكذا وإلى آخره
اللطيف في الأمر أنه سُئل «مناحيم بيقن»
وهو كان رئيس وزراء «إسرائيل» في ذلك الوقت
إن «السادات» أعطاكم شيء عظيم
وأعطاكم الاعتراف بدون مقابل والسلام والأمان وكل شيء
بماذا تردون عليه يا «إسرائيل»؟
قال: لا احنا أعطيناه أيضًا، أيش أعطيتوه؟
قال: أعطيناه استقبال حار في مطار «بن قوريون» في القدس
أعطيناه استقبال حار في شوارع القدس
الناس كانوا يصيحوا ويخرجوا ويرحبوا بالرئيس «السادات»
كما لم يُنظر إلى ذلك في أي وقت في التاريخ
أن جماهير يهودية تطلع للشارع ترحب برئيس عربي
وهذا تأكيد على كرمهم، ما شاء الله، في العطاء فأعطوه استقبال
أعطوه استقبال حار، وفعلًا كانت هذه نكتة
لو لا أن بعض، شر البلية ما يضحك
«شر البلية ما يُضحك»
أن «السادات» يقولوا له: والله كثر خيرك احنا...
بس هو أخذ اتفاقية سلام
هو يقول: أنا أخذت اتفاقية سلام، واستعدت الأراضي
في وقت لاحق
إي، بس هذه كانت البداية
إي، هذه كانت البداية
الزيارة
بعد ذلك صارت المفاوضات في «كامب ديفيد»
وانتهت إلى ما تفضلت فيه أن «إسرائيل» أخلت سيناء
وماطلت «إسرائيل» في ذلك فترة طويلة
الإخلاء أخذ ثلاث سنوات ثم بعدها احتفظوا بشرم الشيخ
وبالشريط الساحل اللي على خليج السويس
وقعدوا مفاوضات بعدها كمان إلى أن أخلوها في عهد الرئيس «مبارك»
كان قد مات «السادات» وجاء بعده «مبارك»
«مبارك» هو اللي استلم آخر قطعة من سيناء
مشاعرك، وأنت تشاهد هذه الزيارة
يبدو إنها ما كانت تمثلك لوحدك، وإنما كانت تمثل جيل أو مجموعة
والدليل أن العرب اتفقوا أن يُجمدوا مقعد مصر في جامعة الدول العربية
وانتقلت إلى تونس
نعم
ويُقال: أن من بعد هذا الحدث فقدت مصر زعامة العالم العربي
أيش رأيك؟
بحاول أفكر هل فقدتها قبل هذا الحدث وللا لا؟
أعتقد ربما أن نعم زيارة القدس
لأن هو باعتراف «السادات»
أن هو زار القدس بدون تنسيق مع الدول العربية
ومن المبادئ البسيطة في العالم والتفاوض والمعارك والحروب
إذا أنت خرجت لوحدك فأنت تُصبح فريسة سهلة
وإذا أنت خرجت ومعاك عناصر قوتك
فعند إذن تستطيع أن يكون لك فرصة تواجه
لما «السادات» يفتخر
يقول: أنا خرجت لوحدي وما انتظرت الدول العربية
لأنه كانوا راح يتشرطوا علي، ويتطلبوا مني، ويقولوا كذا
لكن في النهاية هو خرج لوحده وعُومل لوحده
عُومل إنك أنت أيش عندك حتى نعطيك شيء استثنائي
وهذا الوضع ما يزال قائم إلى الآن
«إسرائيل» تقول: لكل واحد يفاوضها
أيش عندك تعطيني علشان أعطيك؟
إذا ما عندك شيء تعطيني إياه، أيش أبغى بك؟
ويمكن بعد هذه المرحلة، هذه كانت آخر حرب 1973 بين العرب وبين «إسرائيل»
وبعدها صار النشاط الدبلوماسي هو سيد المشهد
وهنا أغلب قصص الأمير «بندر بن سلطان»
والملك «فهد» والرئيس «ريقان» و«كارتر»
كانت في هذيك المرحلة آخر السبعينيات والثمانينيات
ويمكن القاسم المشترك فيها كلها هي جهود ومبادرات من السعودية
على الأقل هذا من الرواية اللي رواها الأمير «بندر بن سلطان»، الله يحفظه
أن في مبادرات وجهود من السعودية
يرمي الملك «فهد» بثقله مع الرؤساء الأمريكان
يدعوهم لفعل شيء للقضية الفلسطينية
يرد الأمريكان بالقبول تقديرًا للمكانة السعودية
يأخذ الأمير «بندر» هذه إلى «ياسر عرفات»
ويحتفل «ياسر» ويقول: احنا خلاص حققنا السلام
ثم يختفي ولا يتمم أي شيء بعد ذلك
صارت في عام 1977 الملك «فهد» و«كارتر»
صارت في عام 1985 الملك «فهد» و«ريقان» أو 1986
فهذا السيناريو تكرر كثيرًا، أيش التفسير لمثل هذه التصرفات؟
كان فيه في الساحة لاعبان رئيسيان
وهذان اللاعبان كانا يمارسان رقصة التانقو
رقصة التانقو كلما يقترب واحد من الثاني، الثاني يبتعد وهكذا
هكذا كانت «إسرائيل» وفلسطين في المرحلة هذه
«إسرائيل» كلما رأت أن هناك فرص للسلام تنأى بنفسها وتبتعد
وتبرز شروط جديدة وتبرز كذا
الفلسطينيين كلما كانت هناك فرصة للسلام
يقترب منها «ياسر عرفات» ثم في النهاية يبعد
حصل هذا في أكثر من مناسبة مثلما تفضلت، وعددت الفرص هذه
في «كامب ديفيد» ثم بعدها في شرم الشيخ
في أيام «ياسر عرفات» وبعده في أيام رؤساء الوزراء المختلفين من «إسرائيل»
آخرهم في هذا الشأن كان «إيهود باراك»
أنا في نظري إن السبب الرئيسي لذلك
أن «إسرائيل» لم تكن تريد أن تصل إلى حل للقضية
«إسرائيل» مخططها لم ينتهي بعد
«إسرائيل» مخططها توسعي كبير في المنطقة العربية وفي الشرق الأوسط
وهي تلعب لعبة الوقت والزمن
خذ ما تستطيع أن تأخذه الآن وركزوا وثبتوا وسيطر عليه وكذا
وشاغلهم بأشياء أخرى
ثم بعد ذلك في وقت من الأوقات تبدأ تطالب بالمرحلة التالية
«ياسر عرفات» ومنظمة «التحرير الفلسطينية»
يحاولوا يلعبوا اللعبة هذه لكنهم يلعبوها بفشل بغشامة زي ما يقولوا
لأنهم يوافقوا ثم يتراجعوا
فلا هم اللي أخذوا، ولا هم اللي ثبتوا على موقف
ولا هم اللي ثبتوا على موقفهم الأساسي
وهذا إلى اليوم قائم
في الأزمة حقت غزة اللي الآن نشاهدها
تجد إن منظمة «التحرير الفلسطينية» مشتتة
وغير ماسكة زمام القيادة في الموضوع
فمع الأسف هذه هي الصورة اللي تمت بهذا الشأن
عام 1993 كان لحظة تاريخية، اتفاقية «أوسلو»
بين منظمة «التحرير الفلسطينية» وبين قوات الاحتلال الإسرائيلية
كانت اتفاقية سلام بينهم
وأتذكر تغريدة للدكتور «خالد الدخيل»
يستنكر مثل هذه اللحظة
ويقول: كيف وافق الفلسطينيين على الاعتراف بـ«إسرائيل»؟
دون أن يعترف «الإسرائيليين» بمنظمة «فتح»
أو بحق الفلسطينيين في إقامة دولة لهم؟
أيش كانت مصلحتهم من هذه الاتفاقية؟
اللي يبدوا لي إنها بس أعطتهم حكم ذاتي في الأراضي الفلسطينية
لكن دون اعتراف بحقهم في إقامة دولة
لا، هي اتفقاقية «أوسلو» كانت مفتاح لما تلاها من المفاوضات باستمرار
واللي كان أساسها قيام الدولة الفلسطينية
أعتقد أن من غير الإنصاف أن يُقال: أن اتفاقية «أوسلو»
لم تحمل بذور الاعتراف الإسرائيلي بالدولة الفلسطينية
لكن اللي حصل هو مثلما حصل عادةً
هو أن «إسرائيل» لا تترك فرصة للتراجع
عن ما يمكن أن تكون قد أعطته في وقت من الأوقات
في هذاك الوقت كان رئيس الوزراء هو «إسحاق رابين»
و«إسحاق رابين» بعدها بفترة بسيطة تم اغتياله
في داخل ساحة من ساحات تل أبيب على يد يهودي متعصب
كان يظن أن «إسحاق رابين» أعطى أكثر مما ينبغي في اتفاقيات «كامب ديفيد»
لذلك تجد أن من الجانبين في هذا التذبذب والتخلخل
الفلسطينيين أعطوا كلما يمكن أن يعطوه في اتفاقيات
«أوسلو» و«كامب بديفيد»
وبعد كذا ما عاد صار عندهم شيء يستطيعوا إنهم يعطوه
فكانوا يقفون على أعتاب موائد الكبار
وينتظرون فتات الطعام اللي يُرمى لهم
حرقوا كل كروتهم
ولم يتمكنوا من الحصول على شيء
وفي هذيك اللحظة هم كانوا أخذوا حق إدارة ذاتية لمدة خمس سنوات
تجري فيها المفاوضات
نعم
ولكن هذا الحق هو لإدارة الضفة الغربية وقطاع غزة
كلها كانت تحت منظمة «التحرير»
بالضبط
بعدين أيش اللي صار في غزة؟
ليش غزة انفصلت وصارت تحت قيادة حماس
اللي تأسست قبلها بكم سنة عام 1987؟
خليني أقول لك شغلة قبل لا أجيبك على ذلك
وهي أن في هذه الأثناء
كانت «إسرائيل» تنشر المستوطنات بكثافة أكبر
داخل الأراضي الفلسطينية
وداخل الضفة الغربية على وجه الخصوص
وكانت تسعى إلى زيادة عدد المستوطنين في داخل الضفة الغربية
وبالتالي هذا كان يُخلي كل شيء من مضمونه
وما عاد يُصبح هناك شيء يستطيعوا أنهم يعملوه
بالنسبة للفلسطينيين، وأيش اللي صار في غزة؟
غزة أُخليت من الاحتلال الإسرائيلي في وقت من الأوقات
لأنه كان الاحتلال الإسرائيلي باهظ الثمن على «إسرائيل»
كانت غزة أرض كثيفة السكان
الناس فيها بشكل كبير، وصغيرة الحجم
أي اقتحام إسرائيلي ينتج عنه خسائر بشرية كبيرة
وهذا اللي مخليهم يترددوا في الاقتحام الإسرائيلي حتى الآن
نفس الظاهرة ونفس الشيء اللي حاصل
الإسرائيليين يريدون أن يحتفظوا بالكعكة، ويأكلوها في نفس الوقت
ما استطاعوا أن يفعلوا ذلك في غزة، فاضطروا إنهم يخلوا غزة
لكن في الضفة الغربية كانوا مستعدين، وما زالوا مستمرين في ذلك
المستوطنات
فحتى من حيث لو افترضنا أن قرار الأمم المتحدة بتقسيم الدولتين قرار عادل وصحيح
حتى هذا القرار لم يحترمه الإسرائيليين
وجالسين يبنون مستوطنات في الأراضي الفلسطينية
بالضبط
فما هم حاطين حد لحدودهم
هم أخذوا اللي أعطوا لهم وثبتوه، وبدأوا يتوسعون فيه
هم في بروتوكولاتهم وأحكامهم وأعرافهم ورواياتهم التاريخية
أن حدودهم من النيل إلى الفرات
لا ينتظروا ولا يقفون عند هذا الحد
اللي منهم يقول لك: لا، ما هو معقول، ومدري أيش هو وكذا
يعودون ويقولوا: من النهر إلى البحر
يعني كامل أرض فلسطين لا بد أنها تستوعب منهم
فهذه أهدافهم واضحة، وما زالوا متمسكين بها
كيف انفصلت غزة عن منظمة التحرير؟
كان هناك خلاف مستمر بين منظمة التحرير الفلسطينية وبين حركة فتح
بالدرجة الأولى، وبين حماس
حماس اللي فازت في الانتخابات في غزة، وبالتالي سيطرت على غزة
وفتح فازت في الانتخابات في الضفة الغربية، وسيطرت عليها
فتح هي العنصر الأساسي في منظمة التحرير الفلسطينية
منظمة التحرير الفلسطينية المظلة الشاملة للفلسطينيين
بما فيها في غزة والضفة الغربية
كان هناك خلاف بين المنظمتين، بين الحماس وبين الفتح
حول كيفية إدارة الصراع
«محمود عباس» في منظمة التحرير أعلن في عدة مرات
وأعلن في عدة مناسبات أن الخيار الاستراتيجي له هو السلم
وهو المقاومة السلمية
وطلب من المواطنين الفلسطينيين عدم رفع السلاح في وجه «إسرائيل»
وأننا ما راح نحصل على شيء نتيجة المقاومة المسلحة
وكان وجهة نظر الحماس هي المقاومة المسلحة
أن المقاومة السلمية لم تأتي أُكلها، ولم تأتي بنتائج
ولم يصدر عنها شيء حتى الآن
وإذا كان «محمود عباس» يقول عنده وسيلة للحصول على تنازلات
من «إسرائيل» بالمقاومة السلمية، يتفضل يورّينا
هذا احنا عشرين أو ثلاثين سنة من أيام «أوسلو» إلى الآن ما صار شيء
فالخلاف هذا كان مُستمر
استراتيجي
خلاف استراتيجي
وكان ينعكس على أداء الإدارة الفلسطينية في غزة
لأن الإدارة الفلسطينية في غزة كانت مكوّنة من الطرفين
في النهاية حماس حسمت الأمر، وطردت الفتحيين من غزة
واستولت على الحكم، وقالت لهم: دبروا نفسكم
وهذا عقّد المشهد لأن صار ما في...
صار ما في قيادة موحدة
طرف واحد أو قيادة موحدة للقضية الفلسطينية
احنا نقول: العرب متشرذمين
بالضبط
وهذا ضيع حقوقهم، الآن الفلسطينيين نفسهم متشرذمين
والآن تشرذموا حتى من داخل الفلسطينيين
ولذلك كان في مبادرة تاريخية من الملك عبدالله، الله يرحمه
في فبراير 2007 لما دعا
القاد الفلسطينيين
وجلسوا أشهر مفاوضات حسب حديث الأمير «بندر بن سلطان»
ويروي الأمير «بندر» أن الملك عبدالله قال: يا سعود
يقصد الأمير «سعود الفيصل» الله يرحمه، ويرحمهم جميعًا
خذوا الاثنين عند الكعبة، وخلهم يثبتون هذه المصالحة
ثم عادوا لفلسطين، وما لبثوا أسابيع قليلة حتى تفجرت الأمور
شيء غريب وغير مفهوم
أيش اللي يدفعهم للعودة إلى نقطة الصفر بعد هذا المشوار
أضف إلى ذلك، بعهد الملك «خالد» الله يرحمه
كان هناك مؤتمر قمة، وكان فيه القيادات الفلسطينية وعدد من الرؤوساء الدول
وجاء «ياسر عرفات» عند الملك «خالد»
وقال له: يا جلالة الملك أنا أطلب منك طلب أنك أنت تجمع الفلسطينيين
تحت باب الكعبة، وتحت ستارة الكعبة
وأن نلتزم أمامك بالوحدة وبالعمل السوي وكذا
والملك «خالد» طالع فيه، وقال له: يا «ياسر»
تبون تكذبون على ربنا أيضًا؟
ما كفاكم كذبتوا على الناس كلهم، تبون تكذبون على الله
لا أنا لن أقوم بذلك، ولن أفعل ذلك
فالملك «خالد» كان حصيف وتجنب ذلك
أيش تفسير هذا الأمر؟ الله أعلم
خلنا أنا أكون أكثر جرأة وبقول التفسير اللي يتداول
«جاريد كوشنر» كبير المستشارين للرئيس السابق ترامب
في مقابلة قريبة قبل أيام قليلة كان يتكلم عن أن اجتماعاته مع الأطراف الفلسطينية
كان يرى فيها أن ما في أي حافز لهم لإنهاء القضية
بل خطر أن تنتهي القضية لأنها اليوم مصدر لتدفق الأموال والملايين لهم
هذا كلام «جاريد كوشنر»
هل نقدر نربط بين هذا الكلام، وبين افتعال الأزمات المتكرر
وعدم بذل أي جهد لحل القضية؟
أن يقول هذا الكلام «جاريد كوشنر» فلا يستغرب
لأن «جاريد كوشنر» يريد أن يزرع الفتنة بين الفلسطينيين
وبين العرب والفلسطينيين
وأن يزرع الشك فيما بينهم، وما إلى ذلك
أنا ما عندي شيء يثبت أن هذا الكلام ما هو صحيح
لكن شعوري بذاتي أن ما يمكن أن نسيء الظن إلى هذا الحد في الفلسطينيين
مو الفلسطينيين، القيادة الفلسطينية
أو القيادة الفلسطينية، حتى هؤلاء اللي في القيادة الفلسطينية
ناس كثير منهم لهم تاريخ في الحرب والنضال، وما إلى ذلك
لا أتصور أن احنا نستطيع أن نلغي مساهماتهم كلها بهذا الأمر
أعتقد أن هناك اختلافات فكرية وعقاعدية وعقدية واضحة في هذا الشأن
وفي طريقة المعالجة وفي طريقة الذهاب
وكانت هناك قيادة ضعيفة باستمرار
حتى ياسر عرفات اللي كان يعتبر أقوى قائد فلسطيني
في العشرين أو الثلاثين سنة الماضية
هو يقول: أن توصل إلى اتفاق شبه كامل
في شرم الشيخ مع «أولمرت» ومع «باراك»
واللي هو الاتفاق التالي لمفاوضات «كامب دايفد»
بين الفلسطينيين والإسرائيليين
ولكن في النهاية تراجع عنها
لأنه كان يخشى من التهمة التاريخية بالتفريط في القضية الفلسطينية
هناك من الفلسطينيين من يقول: أن يا جماعة يا فلسطينيين يا قادة فلسطين
لا توقعوا على شيء
إذا ما تقدروا تجيبوا الشيء المطلوب للشعب الفلسطيني بالكامل
كامل فلسطين أو كامل الضفة الغربية وقطاع غزة، وما إلى ذلك
واتركوها لا توقعوا
خلوا الجيل القادم أو الجيل اللي بعده
يمكن هو يستطيع أن يحصل على ما لم نستطع احنا أن نحصل عليه
كانت هذه وجهة نظر موجودة وما زالت سائدة في بعض الأوسائط
أنا في نظري أنها وجهة نظر غير واقعية
أن احنا نتخلى عن مسؤولياتنا في مواجهة الصراع
ونقول: خلوه لأبناءنا وأبناء أبناءنا أو أحفادهم أنهم يعالجوا القضية هذه
هذا...
وتاريخيًّا ثبت أن كل جيل يأتي بمشهد أكثر تعقيدًا وأصعب
أكثر تعقيدًا وأصعب، صحيح
من اللي قبله
صحيح، فأنا ما أتصور أنه نستطيع أن نقول: هو مصالح شخصية
قد يكون فيه جزء من ذلك صحيح لكن ما عندي ما يجعلني أجزم بذلك
يمكن من أهم المبادرات واللي كانت دائمًا يشار إليها
ويعاد الحديث لها كمرجع هي مبادرة الملك «عبدالله»
أو المبادرة العربية 2002
2002 نعم
أيش بالضبط تفاصيل هذه المبادرة؟
وليش لم يكتب لها النجاح رغم أنه فيه إجماع عربي لأول مرة على المبادرة؟
المبادرة بسيطة
سووا قضيتكم مع الفلسطينيين، وتعالوا نعمل معكم تطبيع
العالم العربي والعالم الإسلامي
في المرحلة الأولى المملكة العربية السعودية
ثم تبنت المبادرة الجامعة العربية، وأصبحت مبادرة عربية
ثم تبنتها منظمة التعاون الإسلامي فأصبحت مبادرة إسلامية
أيش المطلوب من الإسرائيليين؟
إخلاء الأراضي الفلسطينية المحتلة في عام 1967
السماح بإقامة الدولة الفلسطينية
التوصل إلى حل لعودة اللاجئين
مُناصفة القدس بحيث تصبح عاصمة للدولتين
هذه عناصر التسوية الأساسية
اللي ما زالت إلى الآن هي العناصر القائمة
اقبلوا فيها، وتعالوا الله يحييكم
لكن «إسرائيل» كما ذكرت لك سابقًا
«إسرائيل» أعتقد أنها بعيدة عن أجواء المصالحة والسلام
«إسرائيل» ما زالت مرتاحة في الوضع القائم
وكلما صار مشكلة وصار العالم، ومش عارف كيف
تأتي وتعطي ضربة قوية عنيفة للفلسطينيين
ويسكتوا لفترة من الزمن، والعالم ما قاعد...
لم يستطع العالم أن يتفق في مجلس الأمن على قرار أمس
حتى بوقف إطلاق النار أو إدخال المساعدات الإنسانية وكذا
أشياء بسيطة أساسية
وهذه المبادرة ماتت أو تعتبر انتهت؟
مبادرة السلام العربية؟
إي
لا ما ماتت، أنا أعتقد أنها ما زالت حية
لأنها ما زالت تعتبر أساس...
هل لها أي فرص؟
أعتقد ذلك، أعتقد أن لها فرصة قوية في النجاح
إذا العالم استطاع أن يضغط على «إسرائيل» بقبولها
إلى الآن «إسرائيل» تكاد تكون الدولة الوحيدة
اللي لم تقبل المبادرة العربية
حتى أمريكا قبلت بالمبادرة العربية
تقول: نقبل بها كأساس للمفاوضات
أنه يمكن تتعدل شيء بسيط أثناء المفاوضات، لكن على الأقل كمدخل
تكون بداية
وصار في 2013 حدث مهم
بأن بعد مفاوضات طويلة جدًّا فازت السعودية بمقعد في مجلس الأمن
ثم انسحبت منه في حدث مفاجئ
يا رب أني ألقي جواب منك لأني سمعت مقابلتك مع «عضوان الأحمري»
وقلت نخلي التاريخ يحكم
بعدين سمعت مقابلتك مع «المديفر» وقلت: خلي التاريخ يحكم
جاء التاريخ، عدينا الحين عشر سنوات من تلك اللحظة
أيش الفكرة من هذا الانسحاب؟
أنت تسألني، وأنا لا أعرف
لأن القرار هذا أُخذ على مستوى القيادة في المملكة العربية السعودية
أيش كانت أهدافه ومبرراته أو أسبابه، أو أيش اللي دعا إليه؟
هل لنا تأثير لو كنا عضو؟
وللا المشهد يوضح أنهم خمسة بس اللي عليهم الكلام والبقية كلهم كومبارس؟
أعتقد أن هذا ما هو صحيح
أعتقد أن أي عضو في مجلس الأمن له دور
الخمسة الكبار لهم الدور القيادي والأهم
لكن مجلس الأمن مكون من خمسة عشر عضو، ما هو من خمسة أعضاء
أي قرار لا بد أن يحصل على موافقة تسعة أعضاء على الأقل
فبالتالي هناك دور للأعضاء الآخرين
أنا أعتقد أن المملكة العربية السعودية فقدت فرصة
لأن تكون عضو مؤثر في مجلس الأمن خلال تلك الفترة
أيش الأسباب؟
الله أعلم أيش اللي كان يدور في ذهن القيادة
اللي قيل لنا أن مجلس الأمن فقد مصداقيته
واحنا ننتقد مجلس الأمن بكثرة في خطاباتنا وفي المناسبات المختلفة
فكيف نكون عضو في مجلس نحن ننتقده أساسًا؟
فكان تسجيل موقف؟
كان تسجيل موقف، وهذا وجهة نظر سليمة ما في شكل ما أحد يقدر يقاومها
كان يُقال: أن مجلس الأمن مُسيّس ومحكوم بسلطة الدول العظمى
فليش احنا نورط نفسنا بينهم
ونطالب باتخاذ مواقف على كل قضية
واحنا بعض القضايا ما لنا شغل وعلاقة بها؟
كمان وجهة نظر يمكن تفهمها
لكن هل كان هذا هو الحل الأمثل لمواجهة مثل هذه التحفظات؟ الله أعلم
أنت عمرك كنت جزء من مطبخ القرار الدولي
وتعرف دهاليزه وتفاصيله وكواليسه
ففي سؤال فضولي عند الكثيرين
كيف رغم وضوح وعدالة القضية على مدى كل هذه السنوات
لم يقف المجتمع الدولي موقف مُنصف لهذه القضية
أيش التقصير اللي صار مننا، ليش ما نجحنا؟
المجتمع الدولي يُمثل بالدرجة الأولى في الجمعية العامة للأمم المتحدة
اللي تشمل 193 عضو اللي هم أعضاء الأمم المتحدة
هذا المجتمع الدولي وقف مع القضية الفلسطينية بعشرات القرارات
وكل سنة تطلع قرارات جديدة
أو تطلع قرارات مُكررة من السنوات السابقة
وكلها تحمل تأييد قوي للشعب الفلسطيني
وللقضية الفلسطينية وللحق الفلسطيني
وكل سنة تعترض عليها مجموعة من الدول بما فيها «إسرائيل»
و«بالا» و«ناوور» ومش عارف مين
في الجزر في المحيط الهادي وغيرها والولايات المتحدة وكندا
وربما هولندا أحيانًا
لكن عدد بسيط من الدول الذي يتمسك بتأييد أو بمعارضة القرار
ضد أغلبية كبيرة تصل يمكن لـ 150 صوت أو أكثر
فالقول بأن المجتمع الدولي لا يؤيد قضية الشعب الفلسطيني أعتقد ما هو دقيق
ليش ما انعكس على حياتهم؟
لأن في النهاية القرار الفاعل من الأمم المتحدة يخرج من مجلس الأمن
ومجلس الأمن آلية اتخاذ القرار فيه تتطلب توافق الخمسة الكبار
لأن إذا أحد فيهم مارس الفيتو ينتهي القرار
أمس شفنا فيتو رباعي أو ثلاثي
أمريكا وبريطانيا وفرنسا مارسوا الفيتو على القرار الروسي المقترح
بالتالي هذا مجلس الأمن
هذا هو مجلس القيادة في الأمم المتحدة
إذن لا يكفي أن يقف المجتمع الدولي مع الشعب الفلسطيني
لا بد أن تكون هذه الدول الثلاث أو الخمس في مجلس الأمن
احنا عندنا تأييد قوي من الاتحاد الروسي والصين
وتأييد لا بأس به من فرنسا، وتأييد أقل شوية من بريطانيا
وعندنا موقف أمريكي متحيز لـ«إسرائيل» تمامًا
وفي ظل الأوضاع الحالية لا يمكن أن تحصل...
ما أحد قادر يفهم ليش أمريكا العظمى بكل إمكانياتها
جالسة تربط نفسها، وترهن مصالحها بهذا الكيان المشاغب المزعج
اللي يسود الوجه، زي ما يقولون
أفعال «إسرائيل» مُحرجة للرئيس بايدن وللرؤساء الأمريكان
من ناحية أنها تناقض المبادئ الأمريكية والخطاب الأمريكي
أيش لاقين فيها حتى يضعون كل ثقلهم خلف «إسرائيل»؟
ماسكين عليهم صور وللا؟
لو أنت عرفت الجواب على هذا السؤال أو أنا عرفت
لكنا أخذنا جوائز الدنيا كلها
نوبل للسلام
لكن أنا تفسيري الوحيد لهذا الموضوع هو تفسير انتخابي
انتخابي
وهو أن القوى الفاعلة في أمريكا هي الحزبان الديمقراطي والجمهوري
اليهود والصهاينة المؤيدين لـ«إسرائيل» في أمريكا متغلغلين في الحزبين
ومُتركزين في عدد قليل من الولايات في الولايات المتحدة
وهم يصوتون ككتلة واحدة في القضايا التي تهم «إسرائيل» والعرب
يصوتون ضد الموقف العربي مع الموقف الإسرائيلي
وهذا التصويت ككتلة واحدة يعطيهم وزن أكبر من حجمهم
لأن إذا كان المفروض عدد الناس اللي يصوتوا عشرة
وثلاثة منهم ما يصوتوا إطلاقًا
لأنهم كسلانين، وما هم مهتمين إلى آخره
السبعة الباقيين يتقسمون على عدد من القضايا
فيهم ثلاثة مُتكتلين لقضية واحدة
هؤلاء يكفون لترجيح كفة هذه القضية، وهي...
فقوة اللوبي الصهيوني هو في تماسكة واتحاده
وهو يسيطر على الاقتصاد والبنوك والإعلام وأشياء كثيرة
هناك نفور في المجتمع الأمريكي من النفوذ الصهيوني بشكل عام
ومن «إسرائيل» وكذا
لكن هذا النفور لا يجد طريقًا للتعبير عن نفسه
لأنه يُتهم باللاسامية وبالعنصرية ويتهم بأشياء من هذا القبيل
تجد أن هناك فئة قوية جدًّا بارزة في أمريكا ويزداد نموها وتكتلها
وهي فئة المسيحيين الإفنجيليين
الآن تقدر بعشرات الملايين في أمريكا
وهؤلاء يؤمنون بتفسير معين للإنجيل والتوراة الذي يصب في مصلحة «إسرائيل»
وهو أن الله، سبحانه وتعالى، يريد لليهود أن يتجمعوا في أرض فلسطين
حتى يخصف بهم
ولذلك هم ما هو حبًا في اليهود
اللي يقولوا روحوا أرض فلسطين
وإنما لأنه تحقيقًا للنبوءة التي يعتقدون بها
وهي أنهم لا بد أنهم ينتقلوا كلهم إلى أرض فلسطين
ولا بد أن تقوم دولة «إسرائيل» ثم يُخسف بها في وقت من الأوقات
أمام مثل هذا الاعتقاد الكهنوتي من الصعب أنك تتحاور معهم
لأنهم ينطلقون من منطلق لاهوتي ومن منطلق غيبي
غير المنطلقات الواقعية حقت السياسة العالمية
وهؤلاء أصبحوا قوة مؤثرة اليوم، وهؤلاء في معظمهم مؤيدين لـ«إسرائيل»
ومؤيدين للموقف الصهيوني
لذلك أنا أظن أن السبب الرئيسي أو الإيضاح الرئيسي
لقوة «إسرائيل» في المجتمع الأمريكي هي في هذين العنصرين
قوة اللوبي الصهيوني وتماسكه
وقوة اللوبي الإفنجيلي المسيحي اليميني المتطرف، وتماسكه في هذه القضية
الدول العربية والمجتمع العربي يتغلغل في المجتمع الأمريكي أكثر وأكثر
ويكسب مواقف
ستظهر الأيام ما هي نتيجة الحرب الحالية حول الرأي العام الأمريكي
هناك من يقول أنها زودت من عدد مؤيدي «إسرائيل»
وهناك من يقول أنها كشفت «إسرائيل» على حقيقتها
وسيكون انعكاس ذلك واضحًا في المستقبل القريب
ستبدي لك الأيام ما كنت جاهلًا
أنا بطرح مجموعة أبو فارس من الأطروحات اللي قد لا أتفق معها
لكن أعتقد مفيد نطرحها
لأنها تمثل وجهات نظر موجودة، ويمكن نسمع رأيك عليها
واحدة من أهم أسباب تراجع تعاطف من تراجع تعاطفهم؟
أنا ما أبغى أعمم مو الكل تراجع تعاطفه
بس في موجة من تراجع التعاطف مع القضية الفلسطينية
أنا سويت استفتاء، ولا أعتقد أنه استفتاء علمي أو بأسلوب علمي
لكنه استرشادي
سألت الناس اللي تراجع تعاطفهم
أيش سبب تراجع تعاطفكم مع القضية الفلسطينية؟
فكان أكثر من 43%
اختاروا السبب هو طريقة تعامل الفلسطينيين أو كلام بعضهم
عن السعودية وعن قيادة السعودية
مشهد خطيب الجمعة وهو يشتم، ويتجاوز على الملك «عبدالله» الله يرحمه
في يوم وفاته مشهد مؤلم لكل سعودي ولا يقبله
خصوصًا لهذا الرجل اللي قدم الكثير لفلسطين
وهو امتداد للدور السعودي دائمًا
مقاطع أو انتقاص أو هجوم أو حرق صور لرموزنا وقادتنا
في الساحات الفلسطينية
هذه مشاهد تؤلم السعوديين، وفي أحسن الاحوال اللي ما تحولوا إلى أعداء
على الأقل تراجع تعاطفهم اتجاه القضية
خصوصًا أن السعودية حسب بيانات «الأونروا»
هي الداعم الأول والأكبر للقضية الفلسطينية أعتقد بـ 6 مليار دولار
خلال العشرين سنة أو الثلاثين سنة الماضية
أيش تقول لهؤلاء؟
أقول: معاكم حق، إذا شاهدتم مثل هذه المظاهر والمواقف
أن تشعروا بما تشعرون به معاكم حق
وأنا أشعر معاكم بنفس الشعور اتجاه هؤلاء الأشخاص
الذين يمارسون هذا العمل غير الأخلاقي وغير المنطقي وغير المنصف
اتجاه المملكة العربية السعودية
لكن لا ينبغي أن يغيب عن ذهننا أن مقابل مثل هؤلاء الأشخاص
هناك عشرات ومئات وآلاف وملايين من الفلسطينيين
الذين يعرفون السعودية بشكل جيد
ويقدرون مواقفها ودعمها، وتأييدها للشعب الفلسطيني ولقضيته
منذ منتصف القرن الماضي إلى الآن
فلا ينبغي علينا أن ننجرف وراء أفراد وعناصر دون الغالبية العظمى من الشعب الفلسطيني
وأنا أثق أنه لو أجريت استفتاء آخر
ويكون موثق وعلمي بين صفوف الشعب الفلسطيني
ستجد أن الغالبية العظمى منهم يدركون موقف السعودية وفضلها وقيادتها
ودائمًا يضرب المثل بهذه الشريحة التي تشيطن العمل السعودي
أو تهاجم العمل السعودي
نجدهم صامتين تمامًا أمام مثلًا تركيا
أو الرئيس أردوقان في دعمه لـ«إسرائيل»
آخرها شحنة من الدعم وصلت الأيام هذه لـ«إسرائيل»
لتغذية نقص في الخضروات
هذه تجدهم صامتين عنها وغافلين عنها تمامًا
وفي المقابل لأن السعودية اللي ما عندها أساسًا مفهوم المظاهرات
توجه جهدها للدعم الدبلوماسي الحقيقي
بالزيارات المكوكية للوزير الأمير «فيصل» لدعم القضية الفلسطينية
تجد أنها ما تأخذ بنفس الميزان
أيش تفسيرك للتركيز على شيطنة السعودية
وغض الطرف عن، بل الثناء وتفسير وتبرير كل فعل يمارسه أردوقان
أو بعض الزعماء اللي هذه الجماعة تحبهم
هي نفس الفئة التي تمارس الانتقاد
وما أسميته شيطنة المواقف السعودي والقيادة السعودية
هي التي تمارس تمجيد بعض القيادات والمواقف الأخرى
هي نفس الفئة
وبالتالي نفس الجواب الذي ذكرته سابقًا ينطبق عليهم
لأنهم هم نفس...
نفس الشريحة
نفس المجموعة، نعم
في قصة جميلة ذكرها الأمير «بندر بن سلطان» مع حافظ الأسد
أن لما صار في تنسيق لجلسة مباحثات مع الكيان الإسرائيلي
قد تؤدي إلى اتفاقية سلام في مرحلة من المراحل
كان حافظ الأسد يقول: شايف الجندي اللي مع رشاش عند الباب؟
هذا لو درى أني رايح أوقع أو أتفاوض مع الإسرائيليين راح يذبحني
فانا معاكم بس ما راح أجي معاكم
ففي بعض الأشخاص يعتقدون بأن بعض الزعماء العرب
اللي يفتقرون للشعبية في فترة معينة استخدموا القضية الفلسطينية
لكسب الشعبية وللسيطرة على شعوبهم ثم أصبحوا أسرى لشعوبهم
اللي صارت تنتظر منهم شيء غير منطقي ولا يوازي المصالح
فهل أصبح العالم العربي أسير لقضية ضخمها الزعماء العرب أكبر مما يجب؟
لا، هم لم يضخموها هي القضية ضخمة، وهي في هذا الواقع
لكن الحديث عن أن هناك عدد من الزعماء العرب
استغلوها
الذين استغلوا القضية الفلسطينية
والذين خافوا من تبعات الموقف الذي يمكن أن يتخذوه
في أي جانب بجانب القضية الفلسطينية، هذا الكلام صحيح
وهذا الكلام هو الذي أدى بـ«ياسر عرفات» للانسحاب من اتفاقيته
مع «إيهود ألمورد» في آخر لحظة
لأنه كان يقول: أنا أخشى العودة إلى رام الله
وأن يكون هناك رد فعل اغتيال أو شيء من هذا القبيل
نفس الكلام الذي يقوله الأسد: الجندي هذا ممكن يقتلني
هو لو يعرف أن الجندي هذا ممكن يقتله
كان الجندي ما قد قعد هناك ولا خمس دقائق
لكن هو استغلال لعواطف الشعب العربي في هذا المجال
أيش الوزنية المنطقية في التعامل مع القضية؟
هي قضية مهمة وعادلة
جاءت فترة كانت هي ذات الأولوية المطلقة
حتى على حساب المصالح القومية أو الوطنية لكل بلد
والنتيجة هي بأن لا هم وقفوا على رجولهم
ولا قدروا يساعدون القضية الفلسطينية
أنت تفضلت بأن أهم داعم وسبب لفرعنة «إسرائيل»
أن خلفها دولة قوية اسمها أمريكا
بينما الدول العربية حطت كل حيلها في خدمة القضية على حساب بناء نفسها
فهذه النظرية أو هذا الرأي، ودي أسمع تعليقك عليه
بأن لو انشغلنا ببناء أنفسنا لقدرنا نساعد فلسطين بشكل أفضل
لا أرى أن هناك تناقض بين بناء أنفسنا وبين مساعدة فلسطين
لأن الإسرائيليين لن يتركونا نبني أنفسنا بمعزل عنهم
ونصير دولة اقتصادية عظمى، ولها اهتمامات كبرى
ونجحت في كل شيء، وهم يجلسوا يتفرجوا
هم لا يناسبهم أي نموذج نجاح في الوطن العربي
وسيقفون ضد نماذج النجاح في الوطن العربي
وسواءً أبدوا في الوقت الحاضر شيء من الرضا أو المداهنة
أو شيء من المجاملة اتجاه المملكة العربية السعودية
أو اتجاه البحرين أو الإمارات أو غيرها من الدول
فهم في النهاية لا يريدون النجاح لأحد إلا لأنفسهم
ويريدوا نجاح الآخرين أن يكون مرتبطًا بنجاحهم
وأن يكون مبنيًا على هبات منهم
يعني يسمحون لهم بتناول جزء من الكعكة أو شيء من هذا القبيل
في نظري هذا هو الذي يحصل في الوقت الحاضر في القضية الفلسطينية
أعتقد أن لا يوجد تناقض جوهري ومبدئي
بين مصالح المملكة العربية السعودية الذاتية
وبين مواقفها في دعم الشعب الفلسطيني
بالعكس كلما دعمت الشعب الفلسطيني أكثر ازدادت شعبيتها
في داخل السعودية وخارجها، وفي الدول العربية والإسلامية جميعها
هناك دول أخرى تمارس المزايدة على المملكة العربية السعودية
بسبب القضية الفلسطينية
وهي لم تدعمها ولا بجزء مما دعمتها به المملكة العربية السعودية
عفوًا، بس هنا ممكن أحد يقول: لا في تضحيات
بمعنى أن على سبيل المثال إذا صحت اتفاقية التطبيع السعودية الإسرائيلية
اللي هي بإشراف وساطة أمريكية
ففي مصالح للسعودية من ناحية اتفاقية الدفاع وأنواع التسليح
من ناحية الخبرة في البنية التحتية للطاقة النووية السلمية
هذه كلها السعودية ربطتها بشرط إقامة دولة فلسطينية أو حل القضية الفلسطينية
ففي هنا مثلًا ممكن يقول قائل بأننا ضيعنا مصالح
مقابل اشتراط هذا الشرط، أيش رأيك؟
هذا الكلام إذا كان صحيح
أن «إسرائيل» مستعدة تعطينا هذه المزايا
والولايات المتحدة مستعدة تعطينا هذه المزايا
واحنا رفضناها، ينطبق عليه هذا الكلام
لكن هذه المزايا ما زالت في خانة الطلبات السعودية
ولا في أي شيء يدل على أن «إسرائيل» وافقت عليها
أو أن أمريكا موافقة عليها
حتى نقول: أن هذا الشيء موجود في يد السعودية
وهل تتخلى عنه أو تقبله؟
أنا أعتقد أن المبادرة السعودية في هذا الشأن إذا أمكن وصفها بأنها مبادرة
لأنها إلى الآن لم تُعلن رسميًّا كموقف سعودي
لكن لو صار هذا الشيء فهي مبادرة ذكية
لأنها تربط الأشياء المطلوبة من «إسرائيل»
بالأشياء التي تطلبها «إسرائيل»
وهذا هو معنى التوازن في العلاقات الدولية
أنت عندك شيء أنا أبغاه، وأنا عندي شيء أنت تبغاه
نستطيع أن نتفق سويًّا على ذلك
لكن «إسرائيل» في نظري ليست في واردة الاتفاق
«إسرائيل» في واردة الأخذ دون العطاء، ودون المقابل
لكن أنا ذكرت في مناسبة المناسبات
أن المملكة العربية السعودية دولة كبرى
دولة قيادية في العالم العربي والإسلامي، دولة مهرها عالي
المملكة العربية السعودية مهرها القدس
مهرها عودة اللاجئين وإخلاء الأراضي العربية المحتلة في الـ1967
مهرها العدالة للشعب الفلسطيني
اللي مستعد يدفع هذا المهر يتفضل، الله يحييه
احنا مستعدين نستقبله، ونتكلم ونتفاهم معه
اللي ما هو مستعد يدفع هذا المهر يجلس بمكانه
لا أحد يستطيع أن يجبره إلا إذا كان أمريكا أو شيء من هذا القبيل
في تغريدة لـ«عبدالرحمن راشد» بهذه الأيام
يذكر بتصريحات قديمة لـ«نتنياهو» في 2019
كان يقول لأعضاء الكنيسة: أن من يريد إحباط إنشاء دولة فلسطينية عليه أن يدعم حماس
هذا جزء من استراتيجيتنا أو جزء من استراتيجية بأن ندعم حماس
لأن دعمهم يقوّط جهود إقامة دولة فلسطينية
أيضًا في نفس السياق الأمير «تركي الفيصل» كان له كلمة
ما أعرف إذا هي حديثة أو قديمة
لكن ذكر فيها بأنه يُدين هذه الهجمات البشعة
من الكيان الإسرائيلي المحتل على العزل في غزة
ويدين في نفس الوقت سلوك حماس
اللي يعطي المبرر لهذا الكيان الغاشم
فودي أعرف رأيك في سلوك حماس وهل هو يخدم القضية أو يضرها؟
احنا ما راح ندخل في نواياهم، زي ما قفلنا قبل شوي
لكن ظاهريًّا هل هذا السلوك يخدم القضية أو يضرها؟
في نظري أن سلوك حماس لا يخدم القضية الفلسطينية بالشكل المطلوب
وأن له نتائج عكسية سلبية
لكن في نظري في الوقت نفسه أن مثل هذا الوقت من وقت المعارك
ليس وقت الخلاف الداخلي والانتقاد الداخلي لبعضنا البعض
هذا الوقت هو وقت مواجهة «إسرائيل»
و«إسرائيل» تفرح بالانتقادات التي يمكن أن تُوجه لحماس
وتسعى إليها وتطلبها وتطالب بها
ولكنها غير مستعدة لأن تفعل شيئًا
وغير مستعدة لأن تتقبل شيئًا من الانتقاد اتجاه تصرفاتها
أعتقد أنه من عدم الإنصاف أن يركز العالم على ماذا فعلت حماس
في الأيام القليلة الماضية
وأن ينسى ما فعلته «إسرائيل» في السنة والسنتين الماضية
وفي الثلاث، وفي السبعين سنة الماضية
وفي الأيام القليلة الماضية التي فيها قتلت آلاف الفلسطينيين
وشرّدت مئات الآلاف الآخرين منهم، وما زالت تستمر في ذلك
أعتقد أن التركيز على استخراج إدانة لحماس في هذا الشأن
وترك «إسرائيل» تُعربد كما تشاء
أعتقد أنه فيه قدر كبير من عدم الأنصاف
وفي نظري أنه على الوطن العربي والعالم العربي وعلى قادة العرب
أن لا ينزلقوا في هذا الاتجاه
وأن يستمروا في التأكيد على ضرورة توقف المجزرة الرهيبة
التي تقوم بها إسرائيل في الوقت الحاضر ضد الفلسطينيين
والعدوة مرة أخرى إلى طاولة المفاوضات
إذا صار هذا الشيء علينا عندئذ أن نأخذ حماس على جنب، ونتفاهم معهم
ونقول لهم: يا جماعة لا بد أن تحسنوا التصرف
وأي إجراء تتخذونه يؤدي إلى قتل آلاف الفلسطينيين
لا يمكن أن يكون في صالح الفلسطيني
آخر سؤال في هذه القصة الرائعة، والسرد التاريخي
على موضوع أحقية الأرض
اليوم في مجموعة من المغردين يتبنون فكرة بأن يا جماعة هذه أرضهم
بوعد من الكتاب المقدس أو الكتب السماوية بأن هذه أرضهم
المسلمين في فترة معينة دخلوها وضموها للحكم الإسلامي
فهم ليسوا دولة نشأت في 1948
«إسرائيل» موجودة من 3000 سنة من وقت سيدنا داود أو قبل ذلك
فأيش الرد على هذه الأطروحة؟
أولًا: هذا هو فلسفة الفكرة الصهيوني
وهو أن دولة «إسرائيل» الحالية هي امتداد لما كان قبل آلاف السنين
وأعتقد أن هذا الأمر خالي من المنطق والمصداقية
ما في شيء يبين أو يثبت أن الإسرائيليين الموجودين حاليّا
أو اليهود الموجودين حاليًا في العالم هم من نسل أولئك الذين أقاموا الدولة اليهودية
قبل 2000 أو 3000 سنة ما في شيء يثبت ذلك
هو مجرد ادّعاء
سيطرة اليهود على دولة فلسطين في الماضي لم يتجاوز عمرها 70 سنة
بقية السنوات كانت تحت سيطرة مختلفة
بما فيها السيطرة الإسلامية التي استمرت لحوالي 1500 سنة
منذ ذلك التاريخ إلى الآن
هذه مغالطة تاريخية كبيرة يُرد عليها بأساليب تاريخية
لكن حتى لو تجاوزنا هذا الجانب، وجئنا إلى جانب المنطق
لو استعملنا هذا المنطق لأعدنا ترتيب خريطة العالم بأكملها
بدءًا من الأندلس، مرورًا بالهنود الحمر في الولايات المتحدة
وضرورة أن يقيموا دولتهم في واشنطن
إلى عدد من الدول في العالم كله، يعني تختلف الخرائط العالمية كلها
لكن معروف حاليًا، ومن ضمن مبادئ الأمم المتحدة
هو احترام الحدود الدولية للدول المختلفة وعدم تجاوزها
أما القول أن أنا لي حق قبل 100 أو1000 أو 2000 سنة
أعتقد أن هذا غير منطقي وغير متزين وغير متساوي مع الواقع والحقائق
أنا راح أخرج من هذا المحور إلى محور آخر راح يكون مختصر
لكن يهمني جدًّا في بودكاست سقراط
أني أوثق التحول اللي تعيشه السعودية فيتحول على كافة القطاعات
وغطيناه في حلقات عديدة
لكن يمكن ما غطينا التحول الدبلوماسي والتحول في السياسة الخارجية
ما الثابت، وما الذي تغير في السياسة الخارجية السعودية
في فترة تملك سلمان، الله يحفظه؟
شكرًا على هذا السؤال المهم
لأن المملكة العربية السعودية تشهد تحول كبير في كثير من القطاعات
وقطاع السياسة الخارجية والدبلوماسية هو أحد أهم القطاعات
التي شهدت تحولات كبيرة فيها
أضرب لك أمثلة بسيطة لذلك
المملكة العربية السعودية كانت في فترة من الفترات
تعتمد بالدرجة الأولى على المهادنة والمساكنة والاستكانة
والهدوء ومحاولة اكتساب الود
ربما بالمساعدات الاقتصادية، وربما بأي وسيلة من الوسائل الأخرى
الآن المملكة العربية السعودية تسعى لاكتساب المواقف
بناءً على عدالة المواقف
وبناءً على مدى تأييدها لموقف المملكة العربية السعودية أو عدم تأييدها لذلك
وهذا اختلاف كبير في التوجه السياسي
المملكة العربية السعودية كان من أحد مبادئها
التي أدت إلى انسحابها من مقعد بمجلس الأمن
أن احنا نبتعد عن الشر ونغني له، زي ما بقولوا
ما لنا شغل في ذلك، ولا لنا شغل في هذا
ولا لنا شغل في الموضوع الفلاني أو الموضوع الفلاني
هذا ما هو صحيح، لأن العالم كله مترابط
والعالم له شغل في نفسه في كل قضية من القضايا في العالم أجمع
أصبحنا اليوم نجد اشتراك من المملكة العربية السعودية في قضايا العالم كلها
وفي التجمعات المختلفة
أصبحنا الآن عضو في مجموعة العشرين
كنا عضو في مجموعة العشرين حصل
لأننا واحدة من الدول صاحبة أكبر عشرين اقتصاد في العالم، صحيح
لكن احنا ممكن نكون عضو في منظمة العشرين
ومجموعة العشرين، ونجلس ساكتين، وممكن نكون عضو فاعل
ثبت أن المملكة العربية السعودية أصبحت عضو فاعل
في منظمة المجموعة العشرين
المبادرات التي اتخذتها السعودية أثناء رئاستها لمجموعة العشرين
مبادرات كبيرة ومهمة
وهي الآن تُشارك في مبادرات هامة
مثل مبادرة الهند في مد الخطوط الأنابيب والاتصالات
عبر الشرق الأوسط إلى أوربا وغير ذلك
المملكة العربية السعودية حققت إنجاز هائل وما زال تحت التحقيق
وهو الانفتاح نحو الشرق
صحيح أن بدأت هذا الانفتاح في عهد الملك «عبدالله»
وربما في عهد الملك «فهد»
لكن الانفتاح الكامل والحقيقي نحو الشرق
لم يحدث إلا الآن في عهد الملك «سلمان»
انفتاح نحو الصين والهند ونحو شرق آسيا
حتى نحو الاتحاد الروسي، قالوا: أنه ما يعتبر من الشرق
لكنه ليس من الغرب السياسي بالمعنى المفهوم
انفتاح نحو أفريقيا وأمريكا اللاتينية
قارتين كانت مهملتان بالنسبة للتصورات الخارجية السعودية
الآن عندنا كل هذا الحراك
واحنا نلهث في محاولة متابعة هذا الحراك في الأماكن المختلفة
هذه من أهم أوجه الاختلاف في السياسة السعودية في الوقت الحاضر
وما الذي لم يتغير؟
أعتقد كل شيء تغير
ربما الجهاز الإداري والدبلوماسي لم يتغير بما فيه الكفاية
وينبغي أن يكون لدينا أجهزة أكثر فعالية
لإدارة هذا التغيير الضخم في السياسة والعلاقات الخارجية
ربما الوعي الإعلامي لدى جمهور المواطنين في السعودية
ولدى القيادات الدبلوماسية في السلك الدبلوماسي ما زال محدودًا
ولا بد من تقوية هذا الوعي والحضور السعودي الإعلامي في الساحة
سواءً كانت إعلاميًّا أو عن طريق الحوارات والندوات، وما إلى ذلك
أتذكر قبل أربع شهور في اللقاء الأول
لما سألتك عن أطروحة يطرحها البعض بأن السياسة الخارجية السعودية
أصبحت أكثر خشونة، وربما صار بعض الاحتكاكات
وأنت ربطتها بأنه لأن صار عندنا مشروع
ودي لو تشرح لنا هذا الأمر بشكل أفضل
كانت السياسة الخارجية السعودية في الماضي تعتمد على مبدأ السلامة أولًا
ومبدأ تجنب الاصطدام والخلاف والشقاق
هذا مهم احنا ما نبغى نتخارق مع العالم والناس
وخاصةً مع أشقائنا العرب والمسلمين
لكن في نفس الوقت عندنا مشروع ورؤية ونظرة
وعندنا رغبة في أن نثبت بعض المواقف وبعض الحقائق
أولها قضية فلسطين والوضع القائم حاليًا
وكيف يتم التعامل معه؟
هذه قضية مهمة ولا بد من أن تحظى باهتمامنا
واهتمام غيرنا من الإخوان والزملاء
كثير من الدول الأخرى متعودة على المملكة العربية السعودية التي...
تعطي ولا تأخذ
تعطي ولا تناقش، وتعطي وتنتظر الآخرين أيش يتفقوا عليه ثم تلحق بالركبة
أعتقد الآن المملكة العربية السعودية في غير هذا الموضوع
وينبغي أن يقبل المجتمع العربي والدولي
بأن هناك دورًا مهمًا وكبيرًا المملكة العربية السعودية تؤديه في الوقت الحاضر
وينبغي أن تستمر في تأديته
يربط البعض بين ضربات البقيق اللي صارت في سبتمبر 2019
واللي نسبت إلى إيران وذراعها الحوثي في المنطقة
يربطون بين هذا الحدث، وبين إعادة تقييم العلاقات السعودية الأمريكية
لأن هذا الحدث كان اعتداء صريح مثبت على مصالح سعودية وأمريكية ودولية
وكان الرد الأمريكي باهت جدًّا
مما كشف أن الشراكة ليست على أساس صلب
فبعدها صار في تصعيد في إعادة النظر في العلاقة
هل تتفق مع هذا الربط؟
وكيف تشوف العلاقات السعودية الأمريكية؟
أمريكا في وقت من الأوقات
زي ما يقولوا: أخذت السعودية أنها مُسلّم بها
أنها حليف مسلم به
وما يحتاج أن تعب نفسنا معهم
أقل شيء يرضيهم، وأقل شيء يسكتهم إلى آخر ذلك
أعتقد أن المملكة العربية السعودية أثبتت أنها تجاوزت هذه المرحلة
وأصبحت في مرحلة تطالب فيها بمواقف
وتطالب فيها بالتزامات، وبالتبادلية في المصالح والأهداف والمواقف
أعتقد أن هذا الشيء اختلف في الآونة الأخيرة عما كان عليه في الماضي
أمريكا ليست متعوّلة على من يقول لها: لا
أو من يقول لها: مزيدًا من هذا أو من ذالك
العلاقات السعودية الأمريكية علاقات مهمة جدًّا
وعلاقات صار لها عشرات السنين مبنية على شبه تحالف استراتيجي بين الدولتين
الشاعر يقول: الحب في الأرض بعض من تخيّلنا
لو لم نجده عليها لاخترعناه
العلاقات السعودية الأمريكية
بعض من تخيلنا لو لم نجدها على الأرض لاضطرينا أن نخترعها
أنت تلاحظ تهافت الدول في العالم على كسب ود الولايات المتحدة
وكسب رضاها وكسب العلاقات الجيدة معها
بما في ذلك الصين وغيرها من الدول الكبرى
الهند والدول في أفريقيا إلى آخره
احنا لدينا هذه الثروة من العلاقات المتميزة مع الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
وينبغي أن نحافظ عليها وننميها ونرعاها
وأن يكون اختلافنا مع الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية اختلافًا حول التكتيكات والتفاصيل
لا يكون اختلافًا حول المبادئ التي نشترك فيها
مع الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية في الأسواق الحرة
وفي الاقتصاد الحر والمجتمع الحر
كل هذه الأمور احنا نشارك الأمريكان الالتزام والإيمان بها
أعتقد أن أمامنا فرصة وإمكانية
لأن تكون العلاقة مع أمريكا علاقة وثيقة
دون أن يؤثر ذلك على مصالحنا أو علاقاتنا الأخرى
يمكن أنا أقتبس هنا إجابة للأميرة «ريمة بنت بندر بن سلطان»
لما سُئلت في لقاء تلفزيوني عن أن الأمريكان
يقولون: نحتاج إلى إعادة النظر في العلاقات الأمريكية السعودية
فكانت إجابة الأميرة «ريمة» ذكية وجميلة
قالت: نعم، يمكن حان الوقت لإعادة النظر فيها
لأن السعودية تغيرت، وتنتظر...
بالتصرف، أنا أنقل كلامها، بأنها تنتظر علاقة فيها نوع من الندية والمصالح المشتركة
عكس ما كان يمكن في مرحلة سابقة
صحيح
فأنا لا أكاد أجد عبارات تكفي لأعبر عن فخري بهذا المستوى
اللي وصلت له السعودية من الندية في علاقتها مع دولة بحجم أمريكا
مع التأكيد على أهميتها وأهمية العلاقة معها
وإعادة النظر ليست شيئًا سيئًا
سلبيًّا بالضرورة
ليست سلبية بالضرورة
الأمريكان كانوا يطرحونه بشكل سلبي كنوع من التراجع
احنا نبغى إعادة نظر باستمرار مع الأمريكان ومع غيرهم
حتى نقيّم مواقفنا بين وقت وآخر
تسألني ما هو الثابت في السياسة السعودية؟
الثابت أننا دولة مبادئ
احنا عندنا مبادئ واضحة وأساسية وملتزمون بها
ومستمرون في الالتزام بها
وبالتالي سوف يسهل على الآخرين أن يقرؤوا للمملكة العربية السعودية
صحيح، هل سيصمد الاتفاق السعودي الإيراني؟
إن شاء الله
أيش تتوقع؟
إن شاء الله، يصمد
والله صعب التوقع في هذه الحالة
التاريخ الحديث لا يشجع بالنسبة لإيران
سلوكها
وسلوكها
التاريخ العميق والقديم يقول: إيران دولة صديقة شقيقة وجارة
وستكون في موقعها القريب منا لآلاف السنين للمستقبل لملايين السنين
شئنا أم أبينا
لن تنتقل إلى مكان آخر
الفرصة والمصلحة موجودتين في إقامة علاقات وثيقة وقوية بين الطرفين
وأنا سعيد بالاتصالات التي تمت بين المملكة العربية السعودية وإيران
في الأسابيع القليلة الماضية لتنسيق المواقف
والوصول إلى مواقف مشتركة في عدد من القضايا
وأعتقد أن بالإمكان الحفاظ على علاقة ودية متكافئة
حتى ولو اختلفنا في قضية أو في أخرى
لكن هناك عدد من المجالات
التي يمكن أن نتفق فيها أكثر بكثير من عدد المجالات التي يمكن أن نختلف عليها
أنا راح أنتقل لمجموعة من أسئلة الأصدقاء
بعد إذنك، في سؤال
يقول: أيش الانطباعات اللي جاءت للضيف بعدما أعلن موقف السعودية
من الشدود الجنسي في مقر الأمم المتحدة؟
وهنا كان الأمير «محمد» الله يحفظه، في القمة الخليجية الأمريكية
كان له كلمة رائعة جدًّا قدام بايدن أكد فيها على ضرورة احترام
قيم وثقافة كل مجتمع، وعدم محاولة الفرض
اللي شفنا نتائجها في كذا محاولة أمريكية فاشلة
فأيش الانطباعات اللي جاءتك بعدما أعلنت موقفك
أو موقف السعودية من موضوع الشذوذ الجنسي؟
أنا أعتقد أن هذا الموضوع فيه مبالغة كبيرة
في تقييم أهميته وقيمته في المجتمع الغربي لدى الدول الغربية
أعتقد أنها منساقة حول تيار لا أعرف مصدره ولا أعرف أساسه
في هذا الاتجاه
وأظن أنه سيأتي اليوم الذي سيعود فيه هذا التيار إلى حجمه الطبيعي
وأن يأخذ مكانه كقضية من قضايا التي تُثار في طرف المجتمعات الغربية المتطورة
حسب وضعها الأخلاقي ووضعها الإنساني
أعتقد أن المملكة العربية السعودية مواقفها في هذا الشأن مواقف سليمة
ومواقف صلبة وواضحة، وليست مبنية فقط على الشريعة الإسلامية
وإن كان هذا في حد ذاته مهم
لكنها مبنية على المبادئ الإنسانية الأساسية وطبيعة البشر
وسوف يعودون إلى رشدهم يومًا ما
هذا يسأل يقول: ما هو أصعب يوم في عملك
كممثل للمملكة العربية السعودية في الأمم المتحدة؟
من حسن الحظ أنني لم أجد مواقف كثيرة في الأمم المتحدة
التي اختلفت فيها قناعاتي الشخصية مع موقف بلادي
في الغالبية العظمى من الحالات كان التوافق تام في هذا الشأن
هناك بعض المواقف البسيطة
على مسألة مجلس الأمن ومقعد مجلس الأمن كان أحد المواقف
كان هناك موقف حول الصين، ومعاملتها للمسلمين في داخل الصين
وكان الموقف الرسمي السعودي متحفظ نوعًا ما
مثلما هو معظم دول العالم
في حين أنه كان هناك توجه من أمريكا ومن غيرها
لاستغلال هذه القضية لإدانة الصين، وللسعي إليها
والصين دولة مهمة وعظمى، وينبغى عدم الإساءة إليها
لكن في الوقت نفسه ينبغي الاعتراف بأن المسلمين في الصين وفي غيرها من الدول
لهم حقوق ينبغي احترامها
قليلة جدًّا هي المواقف التي كان هناك اختلاف في التصور المبدئي
القضية الفلسطينية، ولله الحمد
لم يكن هناك خلاف يومًا ما على دعم المملكة العربية السعودية
للشعب الفلسطيني ولقضيته
أنا راح أختم بهذا السؤال الأخير
في أشخاص عندهم وجهة نظر بارغماتية أو نفعية صرفة
يقولون: بأن مهما كانت أهمية القضية الفلسطينية
فهي قضية ببقائها بهذا الشكل المتضررين كثر
لأن أصبحت شماعة يستغلها حزب الله، ويسيطر على لبنان
وتستغل لها إيران، وتدخل في العراق واليمن
ويستغلها زعماء سابقين في الماضي
فهي وإن كنا نتألم لحال الشعب الفلسطيني
ولكن بقاء هذا الملف معلق فتح الباب لكثير من أعداء المنطقة
أنهم يدخلون، وتوسعت دائرة الضرر
فهذا الطرح النفعي يقول: انجز القضية بأي شكل وبأي ثمن
فمهما كان الثمن هو أقل من أن تبقى معلقة بثمن باهظ على الجميع
أيش رأيك؟
مقدمة الطرح أتفق معها 100%
النتيجة الختامية أن انجز القضية بأي ثمن وبأسرع وقت
طبعًا غير مقبول، لأن بأي ثمن معناته بيع القضية وانتهي
لا، انجز القضية بالثمن المعقول، وركز عليها
واحشد قواتك وقدراتك الدبلوماسية والاقتصادية والثقافية والعالمية
لإبراز موقف عربي موحد قابل للقبول وللمناقشة
حتى تتمكن الدول العربية
ويتمكن الشعب الفلسطيني من استعادة حقوقه
شكرًا لك أبو فارس
الله يسلمك
أنا ممتن جدًّا لهذا الوقت، ولهذا الطرح
اللي أتمنى، إن شاء الله، أنه يؤصل لسردية عقلانية للقضية الفلسطينية
لأن السرد العاطفي قد لا يجعلنا دائمًا صلبين في مواقفنا مع هذه القضية
شكرًا لك، وأنا سعيد أني حافظت على شماغي
الحمد لله
لم تجبروني عليه
شايف احنا كيف مرنين في التفاوض؟
كثر خيرك، ممتاز شكرًا
لا والله الشكر لك على تشريفك، تسلم يا أبو فارس
شكرًا لكم ولـفهدة القصير في إعداد وإنتاج هذه الحلقة
وفي التحرير: أنس الخليل
فؤاد الهتلان في الإخراج الإبداعي
في التصوير: عبدالرحمن العطاس
في الإضاءة: ياسر كدشة
في تسجيل الصوت: عبدالعزيزي المزي وعبدالرزاق المزي
وفي الهندسة الصوتية: محمد الحسن
وفي إدارة الإنتاج: عبدالمجيد عمر
وفي الإشراف على الإنتاج: رزان دهيثم
شكرًا للراعي الرسمي شركة «صفا»
هذا بودكاست سقراط، أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع